bonjour à tous à suivre dans un instant
l'audition de Marie-Elise Lebranchu et
d'André Vallini respectivement ministre
de la Décentralisation et secrétaire
d'État à la réforme territoriale tous
les deux ont été auditionnés par la
commission des Lois du Sénat présidée
par l'UMP Philippe B dans le cadre de la
préparation du projet de loi nôre
nouvelle organisation territoriale de la
République ce projet de loi et bien
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est la deuxième
partie de la réforme territoriale
rappelons que pendant l'été et pendant
l'automne le Parlement et le
gouvernement ont redessiné la carte de
France redessiné une France avec 13
régions 12 régions continental plus la
Corse sur ce premier texte et bien on
peut dire que globalement tous les
apports du Sénat pour fixer les limites
de ces régions ont été balayé sur ce
deuxème texte Marie Lise Lebranchu et
André Vallini ont donc été auditionnés
par les sénateurs avec une certaine
inquiétude certains étaient même pleins
de colère ils ont dû répondre à ces
inquiétudes notamment sur la disparition
du département un sujet qui a longtemps
été sur la table mais aussi sur le sort
des territoires ruraux enfin également
sur le seuil des intercommunalités fixé
à 20000 habitants et plus global sur
toutes les compétences qui vont échoir
au nouveaux territoirees tout de suite
donc retour à cette audition monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs c'est vrai que nous avons fait
monsieur le Président avec André valini
un tour de France avec des débats
républicains à Hu clos parce que c'était
plus simple pour les uns et les autres
de de s'exprimer de façon très très
libre même si euh on fait confiance à à
nos amis de la presse c'était l'idéal et
c'est vrai que le dernier était
effectivement vendredi à quand on a pu
enrichir le texte évoluer sur un certain
nombre de points même si tout reste en
débat on sait très bien qu'on pourrait
avoir un débat à l'infini à un moment
donné il faudra trancher et avoir un
texte de loi c'est ce qui nous réunit ce
matin euh d'abord dire un mot de de
l'état d'esprit euh André valallinii en
est premier témoin comme moi le premier
ministre et le président de la
République souhaite que sur ce texte on
avance maximum sur des accords en amont
avec le Parlement le Parlement a
vraiment sa place et toute sa place et
en particulier bien évidemment le Sénat
dans cette discussion l'idée étant de ne
pasavoir je je
parle tout à fait librement aussi après
avoir échangé quelques mots avec le
président du groupe UMP qui ne peut pas
être là parce qu'il a une session
budgétaire dans dans son département et
qui me disait donc il faut qu'on fasse
permettez-moi l'expression et de la
mettre entre guillemets mieux que pour
la carte régional et le cheminement du
texte le Premier ministre nous a donc
demandé de de travailler sur les
quelques points qui font débat mais qui
ne font pas débat forcément à
l'intérieur de famille politiques de
façon très bloquée mais sont souvent
transpartisan on l'a bien vu au cours de
de nos échanges et quand on dit et qu'on
entend dire souvent vous avez changé
d'avis sur les départements bien
évidemment oui c'est ça se voit puisque
les départements figurent dans le texte
et et quand on fait quand on croise à la
fois la question
constitutionnelle la nécessité d'avoir
des majorités d'une part et la question
des solidarité territoriale d'autre part
euh Premier ministre a tranché avec avec
l'accord du président de la République
en disant on a donc un mandat devant
nous pour nous poser ensemble je dis
bien ensemble toutes les questions
concernant les départements en revanche
dèsh euh dès la discussion de ce texte
de loi il faut que nous soyons attentifs
aux aux compétences essentielles et au
vrai sens du mot quand qui doivent
toujours être confiés à cet échelon il
est vrai je le rappelle toujours dans
les débats que nous pouvons avoir ici ou
là il est vrai que plusieurs thèses se
sont non pas affronté mais ont é posé
sur la table dans le rapport de Monsieur
rafarin Premier ministre devenu sénateur
et ardent défenseur de la
décentralisation accompagnée de Monsieur
crattinger on avait effectivement une
vision qui était des très grandes
régions en maintenant des départements
ou bien des petites régions en
supprimant des départements et on voit
bien qu'on a fait la moitié du chemin
parce qu'on n' pas les très grandes
régions du rapport rafrain cratager
puisque c'était dans ma mémoire 7 h
régions mais euh des ces région
suffisamment grande pour qu'on se pose
l'échelon de la proximité et du lien
entre la région et en particulier le le
bloc communal et et
d'cun désigne à ce moment-là très
évidemment le département même si parmi
les dans les familles politiques du
Sénat le débat n n'est pas non plus et
pardonnez-moi très transpartisan même si
sur certaines métropoles la question
reste posée sur un certain nombre des
compétences donc j'ai fini cette
introduction j'aurais fini cette
introduction en vous disant à quel point
nous souhaitons trouver le plus d'accord
possible sur ce texte ce texte fait
suite donc à la loi mapan qui a créé des
métropoles en France mais a créé un
outil que je moi j'estime essentiel qui
est la conférence territoriale de de
l'action publique qui permet à aux uns
et aux autres
d'adapter les en particulier la gestion
des compétences à la réalité
géographique historique
de des régions de France qui ne se
ressemblent pas et donc l'État a reconnu
le fait que effectivement les régions
sont diverses et que sur ce point des
des compétences qui peuvent être
déléguées en infrarégional par exemple
il faut faire confiance aux élus et ils
sont parfaitement capables de trouver
des accords au niveau de chaque région
de France il faut malgré tout renforcer
les régions et renforcer les régions
avec une compétence en matière
d'économie le développement économique
est une compétence majeure puisque elle
lie à la fois l'enseignement supérieur
la recherche le développement les
transferts de technologies à une notion
de stratégie sur quel secteur on
privilégie dans telle ou telle région et
qu'est-ce qu'on espère en obtenir comme
création d'emploi dans l'avenir donc un
un un vrai volet stratégique du
développement économique qui manque sans
doute à notre pays qui est victime de
cette fameuse antienne de la fin du 20e
siècle qui était que l'économie des
services allait euh substituer des
emplois à l'économie industrielle et
c'était une erreur il faut continuer à
travailler sur les deux piliers de de
l'économie des services et et de
l'industrie et donc un retour à
l'industrie implique que les régions ai
cette stratégie naturellement en
discussion avec l'ensemble de de leur
territoire pour se faire elles sont les
seules à pouvoir euh aider directement
les entreprises je pense que c'est une
demande de beaucoup d'entrepreneurs
d'avoir une simplification concernant
les aides directes et on élargit cette
possibilité des aides directes à la
possibilité d'entrer au capital dans des
cas définis qui sont les cas de création
sur un certain nombre de secteurs je dis
bien entrer au capital mais
temporairement un développement qui crée
problèm à l'intérieur d'une entreprise
on sait tous que des très très gros
marchés peuvent provoquer une difficulté
puisque les intranss il faut
naturellement les payer et on n' pas
tout de suite son son retour en vente de
produit donc il y a des des cas très
particuliers dans lesquels nous avons
malheureusement vu des entreprises en
grande difficulté ou être racheté alors
même qu'elles auraient pu être sauvé
être en pleine forme aujourd'hui si on
avait permis cette entrée plus rapide au
capital qui aujourd'hui demande un
passage devant le Conseil d'État donc
aide directe entrée temporaire au
capital tout ce qui liit au au au ticket
de d'aide en terme de banque publique
BPI mais aussi accord passé avec la BEI
on a eu de longs échanges à Bruxelles
avec les deux commissairirees en charge
il semble en effet que sur les tiquets
bancaires de longue durée par exemple
les régions pourraient être amenées à
discuter de leur garantiese sur des
secteurs hautement risqués en terme de
technologie en particulier quel qu'en
soit les nature donc les régions sont
confortées elles sont confortées sur
tout ce qui est enseignement
pardon formation professionnelle et la
question a été posée par un certain
nombre d'entre vous de l'enseignement
professionnel je pense qu'il faut qu'on
soit bien clair pour l'instant dans la
loi ne figure que la formation
professionnelle et la discussion sur la
carte des formations parce que c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui il y a des
concurrences qui n'ont pas lieu d'être
entre l'enseignement initial lycée
professionnel ou technique et les
formations de
type apprentissage ou récurrence quel
qu' soit les nature pte par les Chambres
de métiers les chambres de commerces ou
d'autres organisations donc on a besoin
de cette rationalisation en revanche
nous ne sommes pas allés jusqu'à ce que
un certain nombre de vos collègues ont
demandé qui est l'enseignement
professionnel mais tout tout le volet
formation est un volet
déterminant je vais accélérer parce que
Mo je Seris trop longue les régions
conduisent énormément de schémas ce qui
veut dire beaucoup d'études beaucoup de
recherches beaucoup de temps cadre
beaucoup de dépenses publiques et nous
pensons que ces études les régions sont
contraintes de de les faire de les
conduire pardon mais elles sont pas
forcément utiles donc l'idée c'est de
dire on arrête de faire autant de
schémas on en on en fait deux on fait le
schéma régional du développement
économique de l'internationalisation des
entreprises et de l'Exportation avec un
certain nombre d'acteurs qui seront
présents et qui pouront effectivement
discuter des nouveaux
créneaux dont je parle la tout à l'heure
à choisir par la par les régions bien
évidemment et puis un schéma régional
d'aménagement du territoire non pas à la
parcell même pas au territoire communal
mais un schéma en particulier portant
sur les mobilités les infrastructures
parce que c'est vrai qu'on voit aussi
émerger des scottes et parfois des PLU
qui se construisent autour de leur
histoire et et qui voit arriver un
poulgard par exemple ou ou
d'intermodalité qui change tout et qui
les les oblige à tout recommencer donc
d'où l'idée d'avoir un un un vrai
engagement des région sur un certain
nombre d'infrastructures structurant en
terme en particulier de mobilité mais
aussi de localisation je sais pas de
laboratoire de recherche ou autres
outils de ce type et qui permettent
après aux collectivités et au blocs
communal en particulier de mieux
travailler sur les scottes et les plu
donc ce schéma
ouvre discussion hein on l'a on l'a bien
vu sur ce son contenu son opposé ité ou
sa
cohérence voilà je je veux pas aller
plus loin je sais qu' est posé la
question dans beaucoup de de groupes sur
l'exécutif et le délibératif mais nous
n'avons pas voulu ouvrir ce sujet qui ne
nous semble pas relevé en tout cas André
valign et moi partageons cette idée
relever immédiatement des compétences
mais bien d'un autre d'une autre d'un
autre texte de loi s'il fallait y
arriver mais bien sûr tout débat est
naturellement enrichissant et acceptable
sur le les départements la la nouveauté
en fait effectivement c'est la fin de la
de compétence générale comme pour les
régions mais la création d'une
compétence solidarité territoriale qui
n'existe plus qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui en fait ce sont des
politiques d'aide aux communes que
conduisent la majorité des des
départements et comment décrire une
compétence de ce type quand il y a pas
de clause de de compétence générale elle
avait été supprimée ce qui interdisait
toute intervention sur
l'économiqueisait toute intervention sur
les écoles interdisait toute
intervention sur beaucoup de d'objets
donc nous dans un premier temps avions
pensé que la bonne idée était de rouvrir
enfin de réinscrire cette clause de
compétence générale et après vos débats
nos débats nos échanges la conférence
territoriale de l'action publique nous
en sommes arrivés plutôt à la notion de
clause de solidarité territoriale un
projet structurant important pour une
commune ou pour un interco pour un pays
pour un pôle de développement
territorial ou ou toute autre
organisation des des communes qui ne
sortirait pas sans une aide d'un
département serait dommageable au
redressement du pays donc l'idée c'est
bien que c'est c'est la solidarité
territoriale qui conduit les politiques
du département en prenant en compte le
fait que beaucoup de de zones rurales ou
montagnardes en particulier ont un gros
problème d'ingénierie et cette clause de
solidarité territoriale peut compr
l'organisation d'une ingénierie
départementale à disposition des
communes j'ir je n'irai pas plus vite
puisque plus loin pardon nous avons 5
ans après pour nous poser des questions
sur les structures départementales nous
ne sommes
pas du tout prêts sur ce sujet c'est et
je pense que les politiques doivent pas
pvoir dire que on peut avoir une une
idée qui semble rationnel de
Jean-François Copé à François Hollande
en passant par Manuel de supprimer mais
une structure et puis de se rendre
compte que c'est pas si simple que ça à
la fois constitutionnellement
départements sont dans la Constitution
donc il faut une majorité et puis
pratiquement donc on a 5 ans pour
trouver la solution moi je dis on a 3 4
ans pour se poser d'ailleurs des
questions sachant que dans
cette phase pardon transitoire de 5 ans
les compétences sociales et de
solidarité sont celles qui sont les plus
observées par nos concitoyens qui
demandent à la fois l'aide aux personnes
et l'aide au au territoires les les plus
en difficulté et aux communes les les
plus fragiles donc je m'arrête là pour
les départements parce que c'est
l'essentiel ce qui fait débat
aujourd'hui partout c'est route et
collèges c'est vraiment le débat tel que
je le ressens et je crois André a vécu
la même chose sur les territoires que
nous avons visité c'est est-il opportun
de transférer les routes l'ensemble des
mobilités pour que il y ait plus de
cohérence et de coordination
entre telle route tel car tel train
entre les régions et les départements
est-ce que c'est une discussion qui
relève de la Commission de la commission
territooriale l'action publique moi il
me semblait que oui et l'idée des
collèges est venue d'un constat c'est
que sur un certain nombre de cité
scolair en milieu urbain comme un milieu
rural on a aujourd'hui trois employeurs
pour les personnels non enseignants les
collèges les régions et les intendants
donc avec un sujet de rationalité qui a
été posé pour les cités scolaires et je
sais que ça fait débat donc je ne vais
pas au-delà ce matin
euh sur les intercommunaités parce que
je vais le plus vite possible parce que
je sais que vous avez tous lu le texte
et relu le texte que vous avez depuis le
mois de juin sur le bloc communal
entr-temps donc le 15 décembre à 9h nous
discuterons de la PPL de Monsieur péissa
et Madame pieres bonne sur les communes
nouvelles les communes nouvelles c'est
un sujet qui n'existait pas il y a j'ai
envie de dire il y a quelques 2 ans o
était extrêmement peu soulevé et euh et
de plus en plus discuté parce que nos
nos élus locaux prennent en charge un
certain nombre de politiques publiques
et pensent avec juste raison que
certaines communes ne pourront pas faire
face pour des raisons de de population
mais pas seulement pour des raisons
d'assiette fiscale c'est dire que quand
on n' pas suffisamment d'assiette fiscal
c'est difficile de générer des
politiques publiques qui par ailleurs
sont très demandés par nos concitoyens
puisque y compris en milieu rural ce que
nous disent les élus locaux c'est la
montée des demandes de politiques
nouvelles on pense à la petite enfance
et à différents accompagnements qui
quelques années n'appelaiit pas de
politique publique compte tenu des
structure familiale locale donc on a un
vrai sujet aujourd'hui et qui génère
donc une forme al non pas d'engouement
monsieur le Président nous n'en sommes
pas tout à fait là mais au moins
d'interrogations sur les communes
nouvelles qui seront discutées à 9h le
15 décembre dans l'enceinte de cette
haute
assemblée en revanche pour les pour les
communes et les intercommunaités il nous
semble que la clause de compétence
générale est indispensable je crois que
c'est largement partagé sur tous les
bancs ensuite sur deux points forts la
disparition d'un certain nombre de
syndicats
intercommunaux nous
faisons observer que beaucoup de
syndicats
intercommunaux sont correspond a des
périmètres de PCI ou infra
et c'est quand même une 17 milliards de
dépenses mais 9 milliards de
fonctionnement donc là il y a une vraie
interrogation collective à voir et donc
nous voulons supprimer le maximum de
syndicats communaux intercommunaux
voation unique ou multipl on me rétorque
à chaque fois et je pense que André
valalleni et Thierry Mandon qui faisait
une réunion sur la simplification a eu
la même question c'est certains
syndicats département qui fonctionnent
bien s'il y a des syndicats
départementaux qui fonctionnent bien pas
pourquoi on demanderait de les supprimer
je veux dire c'est vraiment la recherche
là d'efficacité qui prime si un syndicat
a raison d'être et a peu de frais de
fonctionnement par rapport à ce qu'il
apporte à l'ensemble de nos citoyens il
y a pas de raison de le fermer mais
c'est vrai que nous
souhaitons qu'il y ait un maximum de de
syndicats qui qui disparaissent alors il
y a
euh or qu'and rendu si vous le permettez
un élu gogenard qui me disait supprimons
les indemnités je pense que c'est c'est
plus profond que ça notre sujet porte
vraiment sur la rationalisation la
rationalité de nos engagements et la
rationalisation des dépenses publiques
je pense qu'il faut faire un gros effort
sur les syndicats intercommunaux sur
l'horizon des 20000 habitants le Premier
ministre a répondu dès avant l'été ou
juste à la sortie de l'été devant les
élus de la montagne euh en en disant que
il n'y aurait forcément dans la loi un
article
d'adaptation on pensait qu'il suffisait
que tout que chacun convenait d'une
puisque c'est un article qui est très
déclaratif il est plus déclaratif que
normatif si je peux me permettre il
utilise d'illeur la clause de revvoyure
de 2015 qui figurait dans l'article dans
la loi de 2010 avec un amendement de
Monsieur pilissard sur un report à au 31
décembre 2012 donc on utilise le même
véhicule pour ouvrir discussion sur les
synd sur les périmètres des
intercommunalités mais avec donc des
adaptations et nos deux critères
adaptation après avoir rencontré
beaucoup d'élus dont le premier ministre
et les élus de la montagne c'est bien la
densité démographique qui doit être un
fait objectif d'adaptation possible et
la distance euh la distance en tempant
de distance parce que c'est pas du tout
la même chose d'avoir une qu voix intra
rapide ou ou d'être à 10h allerretour
d'une capitale régionale c'est pas du
tout de même nature donc c'est bien la
distance entre le centre de ccommunalité
et sa frontière qui compte moi je ne
crois pas à la vision conférence sur
tous les sujets je pense que les
rencontres entre élus sont riches et on
doit pouvoir continuer à les faire
d'ailleurs elles sont légales et et
intéressantes donc l'idée c'est d'avoir
ces deux critères densité démographique
et distance tant de distance pour
éviter voir des intercs qui
chercheraient les 20000 habitants mais
qui n'auraient plus de sens je je
faisais anecdote en disant que je suis
allé marcher entre ces hostes et lourd
parce que je voulais apprécier aussi
quand pris physiquement ce qui est une
intercommunaité de montagne et on voit
bien que les 200000 habitants c'est un
peu difficile de les trouver dans des
limites raisonnables j'ajoute autre
chose Monsieur le Président bah suite à
votre la discussion que nous avons eu
vendredi moi je euh je je enfin André et
moi on on est tout à fait euh euh à à
l'unitionon sur cette écoute quand vous
avez une interco de
18390 habitant en
zone de vitalité démographique il faut
pas à tout prix la casser dire qu' faut
la la raison l'emportera sur une une
contrainte qui n'est pas mathématique
mais qui est un objectif et cet objectif
est lié au fait que euh la ressource
fiscales est rare on en convient
tous qu'il faudra bien évidemment
réformer la DGF pour prendre en compte
le fait que euh nous voulons protéger
les terres agricoles les espaces
naturels et qu'en fois de quoi il faudra
trouver un autre critère que le seul
bâti pour déterminer les dotations de
l'État parce que aujourd'hui elles ne
sont déterminées que par le bâti et
c'est vrai que nous avons un vrai sujet
d'évolution de la DGF pour prendre en
compte la problématique particulière des
territoires ruraux qui doivent protéger
la TER agricole les espaces naturels et
j'en passasse et et donc nous avons à
côté de de cet objectif de révision des
DGF André valign et moi nous sommes
donnés le mois de juillet pour avoir une
mois de juin pardon pour avoir une
proposition bâtie avec nos services et
des parlementaires qui voudront bien
travailler avec nous il faut entre-temps
prendre en compte la ses interconalités
pour leur périmètre donc les préfets
auront une
instruction simple et on verra avec vous
quelle est la modalité puisque l'idée
c'est bien avant voir une réunion
départementale des commissions
intercommunales mais d'avoir en présence
du préfet une vraie étude de la de la
situation pour conduire à une bonne
rationalisation je termine sur un point
parce que je sais que tous les autres
vous les connaissez par cœur euh sur les
métropoles d'cun et beaucoup veulent
rouvrir le dossier des deux grandes
métropoles de Paris et de
Marseille à ce jour l'étude de l'OCDE
sur l'évolution euh
de de du de la de la valeur créée donc
du du produit intérieur brut de de ces
deux grandes air géographieque française
montre que il faut effectivement trouver
une solution pour rationaliser les
dépenses publiques dans ces grands
ensembles où l'hyper richesse co soit
l'hyper pauvreté tout le monde le sait
mais où on a des vrais problèmes à
régler de logement et de transport
essentiellement sont les deux grandes
questions que sont posées sur ces
métropoles j'ajoute sur exmer Provence
une grande question de porte
méditerranéenne et et et de
rationnalisation des équipements sur
l'interland du port en particulier qui
perd de ses parts de marché par rapport
à G Valence et et Barcelone on a nous
toujours la même position pense que le
texte tel qu' a été voté était un bon
texte et l'ouverture qu'on fait aux
demandes nombreuses de tous les groupes
politiques et d'un certain nombre d'élus
et de trouver un statut suénériste pour
les territoires qui permettrait au
maires de ces territoires de d'être
mieux
entendu sur des documents en particulier
documents d'urbanisme mais aussi sur
leurs priorités d'investissement donc
nous sommes favorable à cette ouverture
un statut des territoires nous ne sommes
pas favorables à ce qu'ils ai
possibilité de lever l'impôt euh donccun
propose la CFE la CFE
aujourd'hui sur cette l'air de Paris par
exemple va de 5 à 30 ce qui provoque
beaucoup de dumping entre les
territoires quand on peut faire une CFE
très basse on continue d'accueillir les
locaux de sièges sociaux divers
activités économiques quand quand on ne
peut pas parce qu'il y a pas d'assette
fiscale suffisante pour porter les
autres politiques publiques et qu'on est
à 30 on a aucune chance d'avoir un
développement sur son territoire donc
moi je pense que pour éviter le dumping
et la concurrence je dis toujours la
concurrence c'est pas une valeur c'est
un fait il vaut mieux penser coopération
pour passer de la concurrence à la
coopération je pense que il vaut mieux
lisser la CFE même sur un longtemps même
sur un longts on peut dépasser les 10
ans on peut comprendre he que de lycée
quand on a une telle différence est
difficile en revanche laisser la liberté
de taux je ne vois pas comment en
respectant la Constitution on laisse la
liberté de taux et on lisse en même
temps les taus je pense que là on arrive
à une impasse
non seulement enroit mais me semble-t-il
aussi fonctionnel
voilà le mieux maintenant est de
d'entendre merci madame le ministre
monsieur le ministre peut-être oui
mon monsieur le Président merci de mot à
mon tour
pour dire que je je me réjoui comme
Marise le branchu d'être ce matin devant
la commission des Lois du Sénat parce
que le gouvernement le brancheulati
attend beaucoup du débat parlementaire
sur ce texte qui concerne au au premier
chef la Haute Assemblée euh la chambre
des collectivités locales c'est un texte
qui touche au cœur des compétences de
nos collectivités et euh comme le
premier ministre a eu l'occasion de vous
le dire déjà mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le 28 octobre dernier comme il
l'a dit au président de l'arché comme
nous en avons discuté ensemble monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
nous voulons vraiment que ce débat soit
le plus constructif possible et que le
Sénat apporte sa contribution
essentielle à cette réforme des
compétences de nos collectivités
locales pour résumer ce texte que Marie
Lise Lebranchu vient
d'exposer on peut prendre
trois trois formules aux régions le
développement
économique au département la solidarité
et aux intercommunalités la proximité et
les services de la vie quotidienne sur
le développement économique un mot pour
dire que le débat commence à s'engager
et il est
passionnant sur l'idée de d'étendre le
développement économique et tout ce qui
concerne l'aide aux entreprise à
l'internationalisation des entreprises à
l'innovation tout ce qui fait
l'attractivité de territoire d'adjoindre
à tout ça à titre expérimental dans les
régions qui le souhaiteront le service
public d'accompagnement vers
l'emploi ce serait pour le coup une
œuvre
décentralisatrice qu'on crréit dans la
loi je sais que vous en avez parlé en
commission vous savez que le premier
ministre a évoqué cette idée le 28
octobre et nous sommes preneurs
évidemment d'un débat sur ce sujet qui
n'est pas
facile y compris au sein des
administrations d'État
concerné deuxième mot et j'en auraai
terminé cette réforme territoriale en
fait elle vient accompagner en quelque
sorte toutes les réformes territoriales
qui ont lieu aujourd'hui en ce moment à
l'heure où nous parlons sur nos
territoires
la crise économique et sociale et donc
la crise des finances publiques qui en
découle et donc la baisse des dotations
que nous sommes obligés d'infliger aux
collectivités locales et qui est dure à
supporter pour elle qui oblige les élus
à faire des efforts considérables de
rationalisation de leur gestion et bien
tout ça conduit à ce que les élus
eux-mêmes conduisent sur leur territoire
des réformes la mutualisation entre
communes ou entre communes et
intercommunalité l'agrandissement avant
même la loi passant éventuellement le
seuil de 5000 à 20000 l'agrandissement
des intercommunalités il y en a sur tous
les territoires dans tous les
départements des intercommunautés
commencent déjà à réfléchir à s'agrandir
encore d'autres ils sont très
réfractaires je le sais mais moi je vois
l'aspect positif de ce qui peut se
passer ici ou là des départements
euxmêmes se rapprochent mutualisation
j'en ai parlé l'autre soir en débat en
séance lorsque nous évoquions la lorsque
nous examinions la la loi de finances
pour 2015 des dép partement se rapproche
mutualise leur leurs servicees le Loiré
le Loiré cher leur et Loire la drô et
l'Ardèche d'autres veulent aller plus
loin encore la Savoie et la Haute Savoie
je recevais les deux présidents Guemar
et Monteille l'autre jour et ils veulent
faire une collectivité unique un statut
particulier le débat est compliqué mais
enfin tout ça pour vous dire
que la crise des finances publiques et
la baisse des dotations qui est très
difficile à assumer je le répète conduit
et c'est presque un effet positif de ces
difficultés conduisent les élus à se
poser beaucoup de questions et à bouger
eux-mêmes alors si la loi que nous vous
proposons de voter permet d'aller plus
loin les accompagne les soutient et leur
donne des possibilités d'évoluer ce sera
encore mieux mais je vous le répète les
élus locaux font preuve de beaucoup de
créativité pour faire face aux
difficultés qui sont les l'heure voilà
ce que je voulais ajouter rapidement
monsieur le Président mais maintenant le
mieux c'est qu'on puisse évidemment
répondre aux questions
merci Monsieur le Ministre j'allais dire
chers collègues donc euh et bien nos nos
rapporteurs vont intervenir
successivement et donc monsieur vaniren
donc
oui je vous remercie monsieur le
Président euh Vanini
euh en profiter pour dire que nous avons
des relations de travail avec vous-même
bien sûr mais aussi avec
vos collaborateurs et notamment la DGCL
qui sont excellentes il faut quand même
le dire en exprimant de la
reconnaissance à cet égard et puis poser
sur le texte d'abord un certain nombre
de questions très précises ou de
validation hein donc on a bien compris
que la réforme globale de la DGF qui
devait initialement intervenir au PLF
2015 est programmé maintenant pour le
PLF
2016 donc première renseignement deuxème
renseignement on a bien compris qu'on n
pas sur un texte de décentralisation
mais d'organisation
entre des collectivités
territoriales mais la décentralisation
va nous
arriver incessamment sous peu
c'est-à-dire il y aura-t-il il y
aura-t-il avant la deuxème lecture au
Sénat des
annonces sur des décentralisations
de service gver enfin de service
aujourd'hui exercés par l'État vers les
collectivités parce que dans un souci
d'optimisation de la dépense publique
c'est formidablement important
d'unifier le régime des aides
économiques mais tous nos auditions tous
nos collègues souvent nous disent mais
attention il y a des doubles emplois
avec les échelons d'État
et les les les nouvelles les nouveaux
services qui apparaîtront dans les
régions qu'est-ce qu'on peut savoir de
précis et en tous les cas il y aurat-il
des mesures là-dessus parce que la revue
d'émission et cetera on en sait très
très très peu de choses troisièmement il
y a pas de vraie décentralisation sans
travailler aussi sur la
déconcentration vous dire mais là c'est
plus une info que le poids pris par les
deal les directions régionales
euh et est excessif qu'un grand nombre
de préfets disent eux-mêmes
qu'aujourd'hui ces services extérieurs
ne rendent plus de compte qu'à l'URE
administration d'origine ministère et
que s'il y a quelque chose à faire en
terme de déconcentration il faut se
polariser sur les dral je vous assure
que on perdrait pas son temps hein euh
et ça j'avais envie de de vous le dire
et enfin ah oui j'allais oublié j'ai une
dernière question récurrente il y
aura-t-il et quand un amendement
gouvernemental
sur Paris et
Marseille voilà je
m'en merci chers collègues monsieur le
Président Jean-Jacques yest
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
madame la ministre et Monsieur le
Ministre de nous avoir apporté quelques
lumières
supplémentaires moi je nous avons un
texte qui date de juin
2014 qui avait un objectif clair je le
dis hein si vous désossez le le le le
document c'est ça et l'étude d'impact
aussi le département il faut le
l'évaporer ou le je sais pas enfin ou le
supprimer à terme alors c'était c'était
évaporé c'est une gentille c'est Laam
douce quoi en fait hein et puis euh voà
voilà et C écritpression c'est
l'expression de Monsieur Édouard Baladur
oui mais c'est pas c'est pas pour ça
que et et contrairement à ce qu' avait
moi je l'avais dit lors du débat sur la
délimitation des régions on me disait
non non non c'est pas ce qu'on a dit
c'est écrit dans l'étude d'impact c'est
écrit bon alors on est un peu gêné
puisque on a un texte qui ne correspond
plus à la volonté du gouvernement
puisque vous nous avez bien précisé
madame la ministre enfin on sait pas
très bien mais enfin bon enfin nous on a
compris comme ça il y a des questions
constitutionnelles donc pas de
suppression du département sans révision
constitutionnelle ça on l'a toujours dit
bien que certains a dit le contraire à
un moment enfin je sais pas où ils ont
appris le droit constitutionnel et puis
les les solidarités territoriales et ben
oui ça c'est quand même le département
malgré tout alors moi nous
on on va agir dans un domaine
très simplement on va
reprendre la philosophie de l'article
1er a que nous avions inscrit dans la
loi sur la délimitation des
régions avec bien entendu on a on nous
avait dit qu'on nous écouterait on l'a
vu parce que rien rien même même sur le
le le rien hein et et la CMP ça a été
même presque
caricatural donc on est un petit peu
inquiet on nous dit on vous écoute et
puis en fin de compte nous on préférait
être un peu entendu ça serait beaucoup
mieux
euh alors madame la ministre nous on va
raisonner je vous le
dis en fonction de effectivement
clarification des
compétences ça oui il faut arrêter que
tout le monde s'occupe de tout et tout
le domaine économique moi je vous le dis
peut-être que des des collègues ne
seront pas nous avons l'intention de
proposer que ça soit la région que ça
soit la région
qui fixe un certain nombre de règles
parce que il faut il faut en sortir
quand même chacun fait son petit truc
c'est pas bien ce qui veut pas dire que
sur le plan local c'est les interc et
commeun interco qui font le le le les
zones d'activité et cetera oui bon ça
mais il faut quand même qu'il a un
schéma et puis que le que tout le monde
s'y tienne un peu bon
euh par contre et on se pose des
question vous dites on va attendre la
deième lecture mais nous on aimerait
bien avoir le bloc total savoir où on va
on se pose quand même une
question les régions vont avoir la
compétence en développement
économique ils ont la compétence
désormais totale en matière de formation
professionnelle avec d'ailleurs quelques
réflexion sur comment faire que il y a
quand même quelques petits soucis
sur le comportement des régions même
faut bien le dire est-ce que on
privilégie ce qu'il faut vraiment bon
avec parce que c'est l'objectif c'est
quand même la formation professionnelle
c'est l'acquisition de l'emploi pas
forcément dans la région d'ailleurs il y
a tout un tas de problématiques comme ça
qui sont pas résolu faudra bien qu'on
les
résolve nous on on s'intéresse à la les
région
ont les lycées mais le lycée c'est pas
seulement le lycée ça s'arrête pas en
terminal il y a toutes les formations
postbac et puis on souhaite quand même
leur donner plus de rôle dans
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
là aussi faudrait peut-être quand même
qu'on aille un peu plus loin si on veut
que ça soit cohérent et bien
entendu si on donne la formation
professionnelle si on donne le
développement économique
on se dit mais c'est quand même un peu
il manque il manque un pied à la table
c'est
l'emploi c'est l'emploi alors comment
mieux associer les régions je dis
associer ministre je suis pas
hein comment mieux associer en matière
d'emploi les régions ça c'est notre
préoccupation vraiment et et on attendra
certainement pas la deuxème lecture on
va essayer de faire des propositions
parce que ça me paraît quand même très
important voilà alors en dehors de cela
bah
écoutez
l'intercommunalitécoutez il y a eu un
effort considérable qui a été fait dans
notre pays on l'oublie c'est
qu'aujourd'hui l'ensemble des communes
participe à un EPCI à fiscalité
propre on avait prévu une révision parce
que il y a des choses qui sont pas
encore parfaitement cohérentes on peut
essayer de convaincre il y a des choses
qui correspondent pas au bassin de vie
il y a quelques intercommunalités qui
ont été construites non pas pour mais
contre d'autres enfin ça existe encore
un peu de moins en moins arrêtons de
fixer des seuils qui n'ont pas de sens
qui n'ont pas de sens franchement qui
peuvent avoir un sens 20000 habitants
cemmar toutes les intercommunalités sauf
une font plus de 20000 habitants donc le
problème est réglé ce qui ne veut pas
dire qu'en c tout est
bon voilà et donc je je alors je
n'évoque pas bien entendu madame la
ministre la métropole parisienne avec
ces extensions ces immenses communautés
inventées par le préfet de région ça de
toute façon on fera des propositions
mais ça c'est en tant que francilien
plus qu'en tant que rapporteur de
l'ensemble de la loi m'extrayant des
préoccupations locales voilà les
quelques questions réflexion merci
monsieur le Président Madame et
monsieurs les ministres évidemment la
réforme territoriale intéresse tous nos
collègues et toutes nos commissions s'en
sont saisies en désignant des
rapporteurs pour avis je vais leur
proposer s'ils le souhaitent
d'intervenir après les rapporteurs qui
viennent de s'exprimer au nom de la
commission des lois monsieur Savari qui
est rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des Affaires social merci oui
merci Madame le monsieur le ministre
pour vous dire les sentiments aux
auditions qu'on a pu avoir et qui
parfois limite le périmètre de notre
exercice si on veut véritablement
clarifier par exemple dire que les camps
pour rentrer vraiment dans le dur qui au
jour d'aujourd'hui sont financé à 80 %
par l'État 20 % pour le département
c'est une politique strictement
sanitaire il y a pas lieu qui a 20 % de
département article
40 rapprochement vous l'aviez proposé
des foyers d'accueil médicalisé double
tarifque iation au département
ARS par rapport au mass simple
tarification état ou ARS ou sécurité
sociale hein je bloqu tard on doit les
rapprocher simplification un seul
décideur un seul payeur article
40 vous avez fait une avancée madame si
j'ai bien compris sur le service
d'accompagnement à l'emploi qui pourrait
descentralisé vous pouvez le proposer
mais si nous le proposons transfert de
charg de l'État article
40 derrière
l'accompagnement au travail vous avez
l'accompagnement
social la globalisation de
l'accompagnement social avantage on
reprasse l'usager au centre du
dispositif et non pas selon son statut
c'est pas statut RSA vous dépendez du
département vous êtes politique statut
ass ass et cetera on replaceag donc
accompagnement social global confié à
l'insertion pour la partie insertion
sociale en complémentarité de
l'insertion professionnelle
région si on veut
simplifier si on veut simplifier et
penser que l'insertion dans le cas du
parcours de l'emploi commence à la
partie sociale avant d'être
sociopressionnel et puis professionnel
puis véritablement politique de l'emploi
si on veut simplifier confier
l'insertion vous pouvez le proposer on
peut pas article 40 donc l'exercice est
très très limité comment peut-on se
sortir de ça sinon on clarifiera rien on
aura des grandes idées des heures et des
heures de débats et on n'arrivera pas
vers une loi qui sera plus lisible par
nos concitoyens et je tenais à vous en
alerter parce qu'on découvre ça au fur à
mesure moi je viens de travailler encore
pendant 1 heure là et demi de essayer de
faire les amendements pour clarifier
dans le domaine social à chaque fois
c'est un transfert de charge tantôt de
l'un vers l'autre et cetera donc c'est
complètement BL OK et dans le domaine
social j'attire votre attention puisque
l'article 23 confié au métropole
notamment certaines actions sociales le
service départemental d'action sociale
c'est-à-dire les assistantes sociales et
il y a plus de vision globale pour le
reste du
territoire ce qui veut dire que ça c'est
limite il faut que ce soit par exemple
facultatif et non pas obligatoire on va
travailler là-dessus mais on a une
limite dans ces transferts de
compétences
automatiquement d'autre part j'ai une
question cise à vous proposer c'est à
propos de l'article 24 vous dites bien
plus de compéten général pour les
départements le
grandtin plus de compéten mais vous
rendez bien compte que c'est pas
concevable si on a plus la clause de
compétence générale et que le rôle de le
deuxème pied des départements de
solidarité des territoires faut trouver
quelque chose alors vous trouvez quelque
chose effectivement en disant on peut
continuer à accompagner financièrement
les
communes ça c'est limite parce que
financièrement les départements auront
juste moyens de continuer leurs actions
obligatoires et je suis pas sûr qu'il
dégage encore des moyens pour mais il
faut le mettre et c'est bien parce que
nous y sommes attachés pour le
développement rural mais vous parlez
également que nous pourrions intervenir
et contribuer au financement d'opération
d'investissement en faveur d'entreprise
de service marchand nécessaire bien sûr
au besoins de la population alors je
voudrais avoir un peu la définition des
entreprises de servic
marchand
voilà merci merci chers collègues estce
que Madame léard veut intervenir à son
tour pour la commission des affaires
économiques dont elle est le rapporteur
pour avis merci merci monsieur le
Président euh madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
euh je suis donc pour avis sur la le le
le le bien évidemment la thématique du
développement économique et c'est
peut-être un peu moins complexe que sur
les autres aspects puisque là-dessus on
voit que les choses ont été clairement
précisées sur la nécessité de voir la
région comme étant véritablement
porteuse de cette compétence économique
et en tout tout cas de l'organiser et on
l'a bien vu au travers des auditions que
nous avons pu mettre en place au niveau
des affaires économiques la question
pose plus aujourd'hui sur la mécanique
qui va permettre de construire avec
l'ensemble des niveaux de collectivité
concerné particulièrement les
territoires la gouvernance et en tout
cas la préparation la construction du
schéma régional et sa déclinaison
ensuite c'est vrai que les questions qui
vont se poser c'est est-ce qu'il faut
qu'on ait un schéma régional qui rentre
dans le détail du détail où est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on doit avoir quelque
chose qui reprend les grands principes
qui définissent les grands enjeux
stratégiques et comment ils se
territorialiseront ensuite peut-être à
un autre niveau c'est-à-dire au travers
de contrats territoriaux de conventions
territoriales et on voit bien que tout
ce qu'on entend converge là-dessus et
sur la nécessité et l'attente des
territoires et des collectivités des
intercommunalités queles qu'elles soi
bien évidemment et bien d'être
complètement en phase et en tout cas
durablement branché au travers des CT
cap sur cette construction partagée ça
ressort fortement il y a une question
que je me posais telle que le texte sur
la compétence économique est est rédigé
aujourd'hui alors c'est un point de
détail mais quand même qui est important
on dit que ce schéma régional va veiller
à ce que les aides ne contribue pas aux
délocalisation d'activités économique au
sein d'une région ou d'une région
limitrophe et dans le même temps on voit
que en ce qui concerne les métropoles on
aura deux schémas qui seront adoptés
conjointement et qu'à défaut d'accord
les orientations
adopté par la métropole concernée
doivent prendre en compte le schéma
régional cette question des métropoles
et la façon dont on doit prendre en
compte mais on n'est pas obligé de les
prendre en compte attention peut-être et
et si on pouvait avoir des précisions
sur le risque qu'une métropole puisse et
bien avoir des règles du jeu des aides
effectivement économiques qui seraient
délivré à des entreprises ou des
dispositions qui seraient peut-être
différentes du reste de la région en
tout cas j'aimerais avoir madame la
ministre à ce stade des indications sur
comment on on
analyse cet aspect des choses dans le
texte à ce stade et le dernier point je
sais qu'il est euh le souci de nos deux
corapporteurs c'est celui de
l'ingénierie économique comment vous
imaginez la construction et le pilotage
ou en tout cas la coordination des
ingénieries économiques présentes sur un
territoire régional sans pour autant les
er dans quelque chose de rigide de
rigide qui pourrait peut-être donner
l'envie de se désengager à certains
niveau mais comment aujourd'hui
voyez-vous et imaginez-vous au niveau du
gouvernement une structuration
intelligente et en même temps soucieuse
de laisser de la souplesse au territoire
merci cher collègue monsieur le
Président
tueur merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre monsieur le ministre j'avais
une question à poser elle est assez
courte elle est quel est votre dessin d
e de Z e i n oui point d'interrogation
je pensais m'arrêter là mais je je
voulais dire que ce débat est
marqué du fait qu'il y a
eu beaucoup de d'éléments successifs qui
sont arrivés de position successiv et
changeante on peut théor cela en disant
après tout nous sommes en
réflexion la réalité est souvent comme
cela Monsieur yes la réalité ne consiste
pas à dire il y a un schéma il
s'applique non non j'ai remarqué mais je
vous ai regardé et non non non non mais
tout à fait mais c'est amical he très
très amical donc la réalité cher
ministre n'est pas qu'il y a un schéma a
priori puis qu'on l'applique mais moi je
rêve toujours d'une loi qui dise nous
voulons repenser la France
l'organisation autour de régions fortes
et de communautés fortes qu'elle soit
Métropole Communauté d'Agglomération
communauté urbaine ou communauté de
communes et je pense qu'il y a là une
grande clarté une grande logique alors
bien
entendu je sais bien que ça suppose des
les évolutions quant à la structure
départementale et qu'il était sans doute
imprudent d'annoncer que celle-ci
disparaîtrait un jour
J mais en même temps ce n'est pas je
crois trop demandé que de demander vers
où on va et autant je crois que le
département reste nécessaire dans
certaines circonstances on a beaucoup
parlé des départements d' ruraux autant
je crois qu'il faut affirmer clairement
cette
orientation parce que sinon on est
toujours dans un entre deux alors on
peut théoriser l'entre deux en disant
voilà c'est bien comme ça c'est pas
dogmatique en effet mais c'est pas mal
non plus d'afficher une perspective et
moi dans certains des discours qui ont
été tenus par l'exécutif j'ai senti
clairement cette perspective à certaines
époques certaines semaines et j'aimerais
que l'on porte
peut-être davantage cette perspective
bon mais je vais arrêter là pour ce jour
Monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
Président Madame
Tasca merci monsieur le Président moi je
voudrais tout d'abord remercier les
ministres pour leur capacité d'écoute et
et et je pense qu'en écoutant ils
entendent aussi et que cela se traduira
dans le travail
parlementaire où nous nous
engageons ici au Sénat madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre vous êtes
au cœur de l'attachement au collectivité
territoriale donc il est clair que le
Sénat prendra toute sa part dans dans ce
débat mais vous êtes aussi au cœur de
l'extrême diversité des
territoires et ici nous sommes
particulièrement conscients que tout
schéma
général peut-être contredit par des
nécessités
local par la diversité des des
territoires de ce fait je veux aussi
féliciter le gouvernement de ne pas
avoir baissé les bras les les problèmes
soulevés par cette diversité sont tels
que il e été tant temp de renoncer à à
la réforme donc personnellement je
soutiens cette volonté de de réforme
alors je poser quelques questions qui ne
sont pas du tout celles d'une d'une
spécialiste d'abord je crois que le
thème centrale de la réforme c'est la
clarification des compétences est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
sur votre état d'esprit concernant la
compétence générale parce que le
gouvernement a beaucoup hésité sur ce
sujet et j'avoue personnellement ne plus
très bien voir comment cette réflexion
s'inscrit dans le le texte tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui et et comment on mène à la
fois le chantier de la clarification des
compétences tout en
ménageant une part de de compétences
général autre question concernant la
clarification des compétences mais ma
collègue Valérie lard l'a déjà évoqué
comment pensez-vous articuler la
compétence économique des régions et la
compétence économique des métropoles je
pense qu'il y a là un un terrain très
très important et il me semble que
l'article 3 du projet de loi n'apporte
pas pour le moment de réponse clair sur
sur cette question
euh
l'intercommunalité c'est évidemment au
centre de de cette réforme et en fait de
la démarche qui a été engagée par notre
pays depuis la loi de 99
essentiellement et et c'est au au cœur
de la transformation du paysage
administratif de notre pays alors pour
les
intercommunalités le le passage du seuil
de 5000 à à 20000 habitants a fait
couler déjà beaucoup d'encre et inspire
quand même beaucoup de d'inquiétude sur
certains territoires j'ai bien noté
madame la ministre que vous évoquiez un
article d'adaptation et vous avez même
énoncé deux critères qui me semblent
pertinents mais pas toujours face facile
à combiner le critère de la densité
démographique et le critère de la
distance en temps au fond pour préserver
la nécessaire proximité mais est-ce que
ce seuil de
20000 vous avez des des des éléments qui
vous font penser que c'est un seuil
d'efficacité
pardon bon voilà donc
cette question
euh enfin mais Jean-Pierre suur vient de
de
l'évoquer qu'est devenu l'idée de faire
un sort particulier au départements
ruraux où en est la réflexion du
Gouvernement sur ce plan puis une
dernière question plus
elle plus plus technique à l'article 33
il est prévu une action récursoire de
l'État vers les collectivités en cas de
condamnation pour manquement à une
disposition européenne cette proposition
est-ce qu'il ne vous semble pas qu'elle
reflète une faiblesse du contrôle de
l'égalité des
collectivités j'ai terminé monsieur le
Président merci chers collègue Monsieur
Jean-Pierre Vial
oui monsieur le
Président deux observations de questions
la première où je m'associerai largement
au propos de notre collègue Savari en
expliquant effectivement que une partie
de cette réforme se trouve fortement
conditionnée à des engagements de l'État
si on ne veut pas effectivement se
trouver bloqué par lesffet de l'article
40 et c'est vrai que parmi les sujets
que notre collègue Savari a évoqué on
voit au niveau de la région l'intérêt
que pourrait porter euh le le
regroupement du bloc Formation Emploi
alors j'entends bien Madame le Ministre
vos réserves voir votre position qui
nous préoccupe voir nous inquiète comme
si la réussite de la réforme devait
porter sur un effort et l'ouverture des
collectivités et que l'État était rétif
je regrette la la réussite de la réforme
doit également reposer sur un engagement
de l'État comme si les administrations
devaient avoir un droit de réserve vous
avez d'ailleurs vu tout à l'heure le
quasi applaudissement qui a suivi les
observations portant sur la drale ça
montre bien si vous voulez qu'il y a
là-dessus des réformes qui doivent aller
de paire entre l'État et les
collectivités alors je n'aborderai pas
celui du regroupement des collectivités
notamment des départements quand j'ai vu
la forte adhésion pour pas dire le
soutien implicite du ministre Vallini à
certaines propositions qui étaient
faites ENF que j'ai considéré comme tel
notamment dans la région ronalpe je je
sur la proposition qui était faite de
regroupement de certains département
puisqu'il est même allé jusqu'à évoquer
la Savoie le ha de savoir je n'ai pas
parti parler la la nouvelle collectivité
monsieur le le ministre ne voulais pas
maintenant vous faire dire ce que vous
n'aviez pas
dit mais mais il m'avait semblé par
contre qu'en ce qui concernait le
regroupement des départements c'était
quelque chose mais c'est intéressant que
vous puissiez vous prononcer sur ma
question elle rejoint tout à fait
l'observation de Madame taska que je
prolongerai sur effectivement en matière
d'économie vous avez d'ailleurs commencé
par là en disant l'économie au
permettrait de dire que le moteur de
l'économie est quand même fortement
conditionné par l'enseignement supérieur
la recherche or on voit bien aujourd'hui
la question qui se pose pour les
collectivités dans une région où on peut
voir la la la compétitivité qui peut y
avoir ou un éclaircissement nécessaire
entre ce qui relève de la région et des
métropoles et si je reviens à à la
région qui me concerne quid par exemple
de l'économie l'enseignement supérieur
de la recherche entre une région et les
de métropole que sont Grenoble et et
Lyon quand on sait par exemple que les
commu sont porté à ce niveau-là et puis
dernier point sur l'intercommunalité là
aussi les choses ont été largement
évoquées en ce qui concerne les les
périmètres les surfaces je n'y
reviendrai pas en revanche madame le
ministre vous avez montrer quelques
réserves en ce qui concerne les
syndicats intercommunaux en nous parlant
des forts budget notamment du
fonctionnement je pense que la-dessus on
aurait besoin un peu quand même
d'éclaircissement parce que je pense que
la réponse est un petit peu rapide en
revanche
nous voyons bien que sur la mise en
place des intercommunalités
euh la nécessité de pouvoir utiliser des
syndicats intercomunaux je prendrai un
exemple dans mon département où
effectivement il y a eu un regroupement
qui s'est fait sur un périmètre des
20000 habitants le préfet est allé de
façon très volontariste sur la
suppression et c'est luimême qui après a
été obligé de solliciter la mise en
place de syndicats pour pouvoir sauver
des compétences qui ne pouvaient pas
être absorbées on voit bien que la mise
en place d'une intercommunalité ne peut
pas se faire à marche forcée et que
l'utilisation des syndicats
intercommunaux est très souvent la
souplesse qui nous est
nécessaire merci chers collègues
monsieur le Président
mesard merci monsieur le
Président j'avais espoir parce que
madame la ministre nous a dit qu'elle
était allée à lourde et je me suis dit
que oui mais dans les Hautes Pyrénées
vous êtes allés donc ah je suis je suis
déçu je suis déçu parce
que ceci explique cela j'avais donc eu
un
espoir qui ne s'est pas réalisé je me
suis dit une apparition de la réalité de
nos collectivités était peut-être
possible je crois
que ces deux textes je l'ai dit je le
maintiens sont dévastateurs euh pour les
territoires
interstitiels
dévastateurs partagerai pas le le début
de l'excellente intervention de notre
collègue Catherine taska et je partage
par contre ces questions c'est que j'ai
pas eu le sentiment que le gouvernement
était à l'écoute du Sénat sur les
questions de réforme de collectivité
nous en avons d'ailleurs eu récemment la
la preuve absolue absolue avec le
premier texte puisque tout ce que nous
avions proposé a été systématiquement
balayé bon donc ma première question
c'est de
savoir clairement si c'est la même chose
parce que nous sommes quand même saisis
d'un texte avec un seul document émanant
du gouvernement jilis à la page
5 l'exposé des motif c'est le débat
pourra s'engager sereinement sur les
modalit de suppression des conseils
départementaux à l'horizon 2020 j'y
lis un certain nombre
d'articles clarification des compétences
moi j'ai toujours été d'accord et et
j'avais voté le le le rejet du retour à
la clause de compétence générale partout
bon vous avez changé heureusement d'avis
c'est une très bonne chose mais une fois
qu'on a dit ça le tout c'est de savoir
ce que l'on met dans les compétences
mais queles sont
Jean-Pierre surla dit quel quel est le
dessin j'ai bien compris qu'el était le
sien nous n'avons pas le même mais ce
qui est intéressant c'est d'avoir le
dessin du gouvernement est-ce que votre
objectif c'est toujours la suppression
des conseils généraux dites-le
clairement parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a eu le juste avant le congrès
des maires et puis que maintenant on est
dans le juste après le congrès des
maires mais peut-être est-ce une
interprétation fallacieuse bon mais il
faut le dire avez-vous quelle est la
position du gouvernement là-dessus
est-ce que c'est toujours votre objectif
oui ou non est-ce que tout ce qui est
dans ce texte est toujours et toujours
euh la le souhait la la politique du
gouvernement oui ou non est-ce que euh
transfert
au aux régions de la voirie
départementale c'est toujours votre
position est-ce que transfert des
collèges c'est toujours votre position
avec le contenu qui qui est dans le
texte c'est-à-dire localisation des
collèges et nombre d'élèves dans les
collèges c'est dans le texte est-ce que
le transport scolaire est-ce que c'est
toujours la position du Gouvernement sur
le sur les
intercommunalités seuil à 200000
habitants est-ce que vous le maintenez
avec système dérogatoire ou est-ce que
vous acceptez une
modification c'est-à-dire faire sauter
ce
seuil question claire c'est oui c'est
non bon il y a aussi des problèmes de
délai en matière de d'évolution des
intercommunalités parce que le texte a
pris du retard beaucoup de retard et que
il y a des intercommunalités qui sont
prêtes à aller très vite il faut les
laisser aller vite et puis il y en a
d'autres pour des questions de
compétences différentes d'organisation
qui ont besoin d'un peu plus de temps
donc il faut manifestement repousser à
mon avis le
délai
sur sur ce qui est aussi en bout de
enfin à la fin du
texte Catherine taska a parlé justement
du des pénalités que vous envisagiez de
faire supporter aux
communes lorsque au niveau européen la
France est sanctionnée mais la question
actuelle des nitrates par exemple sur
nos territoires ruraux alors je vais
vous dire que si si vous envisagez de
faire supporter une finé aux
collectivités les conséquences hein des
décisions qui sont prises par l'État sur
les zones vulnérables en matière de
nitrate croyez-moi vous vous lèverez la
révolution dans No dans nos territoires
ce n'est pas raisonnable de la même
manière il y a quand même des
dispositions sur la mise sous tutel des
collectivités au niveau chambre
régionale des comptes puis puis demander
des expérimentations par des convention
entre Cours des comptes et certaines
collectivités c'est assez original donc
moi je je souhaiterais surtout madame la
ministre avoir des réponses précises à
ces questions quelle est la volonté du
gouvernement parce que si c'est pour
nous dire travaillez construisez ne
rendez pas une copie blanche et que on
fasse une belle copie sur laquelle on
aura une large majorité
trans sensibilité pour ensuite faire
voter la destruction systématique du
texte par l'Assemblée nationale je pense
que on pourra s'épargner beaucoup de
temps
merci cher monsieur le Président
Monsieur Yve
détregne merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre monsieur le le
ministre je vais également vous
interroger sur les
intercommunalités depuis quelques années
texte après texte on augmente les seuils
en matière d'intercommunalité à
fiscalité propre on a d'abord rendu
obligatoire l'appartenance de toute
commune à une intercommunalité fiscalité
propre comité de commune comité
d'agglomération et puis maintenant texte
après texte on renforce le le seuil de
de
population avec le seuil de 5000
habitants qui est celui que doivent
atteindre aujourd'hui les
intercommunalités on est à une taille de
population et de territoire où on peut
concevoir une
intégration progressivement plus
importante des communes auin sain de
l'intercommunalité en passant ce seuil à
20000 on va au contraire courir le
risque de la
dilution dans sur un grand territoire de
l'intercommunalité je prends l'exemple
du département que je connais le mieux
qui est qui est la Marne nous avons un
secteur
aujourd'hui où une
intercommunalité compte 13400 habitants
mais pour atteindre des 13400 habitants
elle a du regrouper 60
communes comment voulez-vous arriver à
un seuil de 20000 habitants dans des
secteurs comme comme celui-ci on aura
d'un bout à l'autre de
l'intercommunalité une distance de 80 km
voire plus ça veut dire que aucune
commune hormis peut-être la commune
centre ne se sentira partie prenante ne
se sentira vraiment membre intégré d'une
d'une communauté ça ne servira à rien on
va tout diluer et
euh et et on verra pas on voit pas quel
sera l'intérêt de cette intercommunalité
donc je m'interroge sur ce seuil de de
de 20000 habitants on ne peut pas on ne
peut pas décréter à Paris la population
d'une intercommunalité la France et et
c'est et c'est un des charmes de la
France est varié notez teritoir sont
variés il faut tenir compte des
territoires on ne peut pas décréter ça
comme ça et puis j'ai une question une
question j'allais dire que celleel est
transcourant et même plus que
transcourant
transmajorité texte après texte on on
renforce enfin on croit renforcer les
intercommunités au final quel est
l'objectif est-ce que c'est de couvrir
le
territoire de grandes intercommunalités
et s'inspirant de la loi PLM faire des
communes des arrondissement
d'intercommunalité c'est-à-dire
d'inverser le couple aujourd'hui
l'intercommunalité procède des communes
elle exerce des compétences que lui ont
transféré la commune est-ce que demain
l'objectif c'est d'inverser et de dire
que la collectivité de base sur le
terrain c'est
l'intercommunalité et que les communes
sont des sections ou des arrondissements
de cette interconnité c'est une question
que commence à se à se poser beaucoup
d'élus et si vous pouviez être clair
là-dessus et bien je crois que tous les
élus vous en remercieraient quel que
soit le sens on verrait après là la
réaction à voir mais quel que soit le
sens de la réponse mais on aimerait bien
savoir ce qui se passe derrière cette
cette manie loi après loi de vouloir
renforcer compléter les les inter
communalité donc VO voilà ma ma ma
question principale ma deuxième question
elle est d'ordre générale elle a déjà
été soulevée par d'autres collègues où
est la réflexion sur les moyens
financiers dont disposeront les
collectivités pour mettre en œuvre les
compétences qu'on veut leur donner moi
je l'ai je l'ai pas trouvé
euh donc est-ce qu'on est en train de
faire un exercice où on dit on on
décrète enfin on légifère pour dire
voilà tel niveau fait ça tel haut niveau
fait ça puis on verra demain comment on
finance mais on peut plus se payer enfin
dans dans l'état de nos finances
publiques on peut plus se payer ce luxe
de de remettre à demain la réflexion ou
est-ce que vous avez avant de nous
proposer ces répartitions de de
compétences et ces réorganisation
territoriale est-ce que vous avez mené à
son terme une vraie réflexion sur les
moyens dont on disposera pour ne pas
décevoir le territoire et les élus en
mettant en œuvre cette
loi merci mon cher collègue monsieur
grimier nous avons encore un certain
nombre d'interventions je ne voudrais
pas pénaliser ceux qui ne se sont pas
encore exprimés par rapport à ceux qui
se sont déjà exprimés mais j'attire
quand même votre attention sur le fait
que si nous pouvions avoir suffisamment
de temps pour que Madame le Ministre
madame la ministre et Monsieur le
ministre puisse nous répondre ce serait
bien qui donc je vous invite à la
concision mes chers
collègues merci Président je je vais
essayer de de réaliser cet exercice que
vous nous demandez madame le ministre
monsieur le ministre effectivement euh
pour être très bref l'organisation
territoriale la région la compétence
économique euh oui mais lorsqu'on a dit
ça comment ça fonctionne avec
l'architecture de l'état des des
services de l'État parce que c'est le
point fondamental on peut pas avoir d'un
côté une définition une architecture de
l'organisation de la mission économique
au niveau des régions et ce que vous
avez dit je le partage complètement
c'est attendu le guichet unique
qu'est-ce que c'est que c'est tellement
entendu que je je je me dis est-ce que
c'est vraiment possible et et pour avoir
un vrai fonctionnement madame le
ministre monsieur le ministre du guichet
unique il faut répondre à la question
l'architecture de l'État par rapport à
l'organisation
économique deuxème point sur la
formation
professionnelle là encore je crois que
c'est un sujet vraiment de de fond si on
veut résoudre dès lors qu'on donne la
formation professionnelle aux régions ce
qui est tout à fait leur colonne
vertébrale et on voit bien le mariage à
qu c'est à la fois la nécessité là
encore de l'État la place de l'État dans
le retour à l'emploi sur et quelque part
la notion de guichet unique pour comme
beaucoup d'élus iussi avoir accompagné
des cellules de reclassement quand on
voit l'abondance de de de guichets pour
obtenir une formation non il faut
trouver un guichet unique et là encore
quelle organisation quelle architecture
sur cette colonne vertébrale de la
formation professionnel et quand je dis
mariage à 4 il y a le rôle des
entreprises si on veut un retour à
l'emploi et effectivement être plus
efficace il faut trouver le
positionnement de l'entreprise et aussi
un positionnement interrégional on ne
peut pas et je parle en connaissance de
cause étant dans le milieu
agroalimentaire toutes les grandes
régions n'auront pas forcément des
centres de formation professionnel qui
sont dédiés à des métiers et parfois il
nous faut trouver des passerelles
permettant effectivement d'avoir des
accords entre des régions sans pour
autant recréer quelque chose je vais
terminer sur interco euh pour dire une
chose toute simple euh on a entendu le
discours du premier ministre qui a
effectivement corrigé un peu le le
document écrit document officiel le
projet on s'en réjouit c'est la même
chose pour le département mais j'ai un
sentiment qu'on qu'on navigue un peu à
vue et et qu'on revient un peu en
arrière par rapport à à ce qui a été
exprimé par le Premier ministre lors du
débat douloureux de la définition des
cartes de des régions et et je crois que
madame le ministre monsieur le ministre
n'oubliez pas les populations s'il y a
bien un point clé au niveau de la
structure intercommunale c'est la proité
mais surtout l'appropriation par les
populations et j'ai peur que la notion
de temps
et de densité ne soit pas suffisante
parlons un peu plus finement de la
notion de bassin de vie et de bassin
partagés par les populations donc soyons
plus souple encore soyons plus souple
merci merci cher collègue Monsieur
Bonhomme monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre monsieur ministre euh juste un
élément c'est vrai que entre le texte
issu du document du mois de juin et
septembre il y a beaucoup de il eu
beaucoup d'évolution malheureusement il
demeure beaucoup d'ambigué on a le
sentiment que le gouvernement a fait un
pas de deux euh et euh en essayant de de
de créer des des nouvelles des nouvelles
notions comme la clause de la solidarité
territoriale qui demande vraiment d'être
précisé euh d'autre part euh je je il me
semble que le la faute originelle vient
de cette fameuse seuil de 20000
habitants c'est vrai que pour la plupart
de ceux qui sont dans les territoires 10
ruraux je veux dire entre la montagne et
l'agglomération il y a quand même
beaucoup de départements qui sont
concernés avec des situations très
précise ce seuil est mortifère et va
créer des situations effectivement il
risque de se voir diluer le le sentiment
d'appartenance de ces territoires
d'autant plus que cela se fait dans un
contexte double qui n'est pas dans le
texte qui don un contexte de
rarifacction de de l'argent public avec
la baisse des dotations qui ne manquera
pas d'avoir des conséquences qui a déjà
des conséquences sur la situation
financière des département qui est
fortement dégradé hein les les taux de
d'endettement les le le
l'autofinancement a déjà c'est déjà
dégradé et va se poursuivre donc on va
avoir des départements qui vont être en
tout cas sur le plan financier va être
affaibli et dépouillé de leur
principales compétences pour n'être plus
essentiellement qu'un qu'un prestataire
social
et en dépit de la clause de solidarité
territoriale qui mérite d'être d'être
précisé on voit mal comment cette
architecture peut fonctionner donc il y
a quand même souci ce souci de de de
seuil de 20000 habitants que je crois
que vous
devriez abandonner parce que il n'y a
pas de notion opérationnelle sinon celle
des sinon celle issue des des des
documents Inc qui établiss ce que c'est
qu'un territoire en terme de bassin de
vie
l'autre ambigué vient du mode d'élection
alors c'est pas le texte mais il y a le
mode d'élection des des conseillers
généraux a changé et d'avoir introduit
des seuils de enfin des
des des circonscriptions électorales de
18 à 20000
habitants alors même que la notion de de
de territoire et de de bassin de vie n'a
pas
d'opérationnalité sur le plan électoral
ça va encore couper en deux couper les
les élus on peut pas va dire que le mode
d'élection jusqu'à présent des
conseillers généraux n'était pas
démocratique il y avait pas plus
démocratique que le mode d'élection d'un
conseiller général et et de ce fait avec
le mode de désignation directe ça créé
un lien très fort de de
proximité avec la notion de 20000
habitants ça va ça va le le couper de
son territoire qui est renforcé par la
réforme du mode électoral qui a eu lieu
il y a un an donc c'est c'est un élément
qui est contradictoire et qui ne va pas
arranger les choses de ce point de vue
et
plus aggravé par une situation
financière je lu dit qu' s'est dégradé
voilà donc j'espère que vous aurez la
sagesse de revenir sur ce point-là qui
me paraît essentiel sinon il ne restera
plus comme l'a dit mon collègue mesar a
posé un cerge all à lourde ce qui vous
l'admettraz
est assez étonnant de
et donne la mesure du sentiment de
désarroi des élus quand elle est même
invoquée par un groupe RDSE qui est
attaché comme à la licité qui évite les
références
religieuses merci mon cher collègue je
vais dans un instant donner la parole à
Madame le Ministre et à monsieur le
ministre je voudrais simplement dire que
parmi tous les débats qui ont été
mentionnés il y en a qui en réalité sont
déjà derrière nous euh le texte du
Gouvernement a été déposé sur le bureau
du Sénat le 18 juin et euh il est très
clair que le gouvernement a mis à profit
ces 6 mois qui euh nous aurons séparé du
dépôt du texte et de son examen en en
séance publique euh pour
écouter discuter et qu'il a notamment
sur les départements pris des positions
qui ne sont plus cell que euh le le
texte de l'exposé des motifs et le et le
contenu du du projet avait arrêté au
mois de juin le débat sur l'avenir des
départements était un débat
d'anticipation juin c'est aujourd'hui un
débat rétrospectif chacun naturellement
peut avoir son idée et même le
gouvernement sur et ses membres sur ce
que deviendront les départements en 2020
ou en 2030 mais ça n'est pas un sujet
d'actualité le seul sujet d'actualité en
ce qui concerne les département c'est
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont avoir à faire
demain et là-dessus évidemment nous
avons un débat qui doit déboucher sur le
vote d'un texte qui ne peut pas du point
de vue du sén être exactement et même
qui sera très différent de celui que
nous avons actuellement sous les yeux en
tout cas sur sur ce point particulier
nos collègues plusieurs d'entre eux ont
mentionné la nécessité de transformer ce
texte en texte de décentralisation en ce
qui concerne les régions il faut en
effet sans doute que cette réforme
territoriale coïncide avec les attentes
du pays dans le domaine économique et
dans le domaine de la création d'emploi
on ne comprendrait pas après avoir dit
qu'on veut des grandes régions stratèges
et compétentes sur le plan économique
qu'elle n'it aucune espèce de
responsabilité nouvelle pour ce qui
concerne la lutte contre le chômage et
la reconversion des bassins d'emploi en
difficulté sinon à quoi servirait de
faire aujourd'hui une réforme
territoriale on a là des sujets qui sont
des sujets majeurs auxquels s'ajoutent
beaucoup de questions que vous avez posé
et euh les membres du gouvernement qui
portent ce texte vont maintenant pouvoir
y répondre mais euh les les réponses les
plus précises la véritable épreuve de
vérité ça va être le débat des
articles merci monsieur le Président
effectivement le débat de des
départements est derrière
nous juste une une remarque nous étions
hier en discussion avec un certain
nombre de pays européens sur les
politiques publiques et rénovation des
politiques publiques nécessaires parce
que l'état des lieux montre que nous ne
sommes pas totalement performants
puisque les nous sommes en crise donc il
y a quand même un sujet qui nous
interpelle tous et les Italiens par
exemple ont supprimé les provinces mais
viennent de créer les aires d'initiativ
territorial cette nécessité d'un échelon
de proximité et et quelque chose que que
l'Italie vient de remettre à l'ordre du
jour mais avec un un système
effectivement de répartition de
compétences et de lien total entre les
élus et leur territoire qui peut qui
nous interroge et je pense qu'on
continuera à s'interroger dans les
années qui
viennent le le Premier ministre ministre
a a dit le changement de cap de
Gouvernement sur ce sujet moi je dis
toujours il y a il y a aussi noblesse à
changé d'avis lorsque l'ensemble des
parlementaires que vous avez en face de
vous vous démontre que le choix que vous
avez fait n'est pas le m de la même
manière qu'il a noblesse de la part d'un
gouvernement à écouter le Sénat sur un
sujet comme celui-là il y aura
effectivement des des positions
difficiles des moments sur lesquels nous
ne somons pas d'accord mais je redis ce
que j'ai dit en début de propos notre
objectif est bien de chercher euh un
maximum de rapprochement
entre ce que pense les le Sénat et
essentiellement cette commission et puis
nos vos collègues pardonnez-moi j'allais
dire n mais non de de l'Assemblée
nationale dire qu'il y a il y a des
collègues de l'Assemblée nationale qui
vivent dans des départements ruraux sans
population en dramatique situation on ne
peut pas dire que ils ne connaissent pas
les les territoires dire moi j'ai la
chance aussi de de vivre dans un endroit
où ma communauté d'agglomération dans
lequelle j'habite que je ne dirige plus
du tout n'est pas traversé par un qu de
voie c'est pourquoi je fais différence
avec celle pas très loin qui est
effectivement qui a une voix rapide et
il faut penser à à tout cela nous
connaissons les territoires de France et
et je pense que il faut que communément
nous apprenions aussi les difficulté
d'autres types de territoires moi je
suis attentive aujourd'hui au mililleur
pour des tas de raisons je reviendrai
rapidement avant André Bini mais je suis
aussi attentive à l'hyper richichesse et
l'hyper pauvreté qui se côtoi dans des
grand des territoires urbains avec des
élus locaux qui souffrent encore
peut-être plus d'avoir 40 % de leur
population sans activité ou en situation
de grave détresse c'est pas non plus
facile à gérer donc il faut que nous
apprenions les uns les autres des
territoire de France et je pense
qu'après cette étude et ce cheminement
nous avons conduit d'chang sur le
territoire de France il n'y a plus de
sujet de suppression des départements et
je pense que le choix des régions et du
nombre de régions impliquer cet échelon
d'initiative territoriale il faudra
après se poser d'autres questions je
disais très franchement
à un collègue parlementairire à
l'Assemblée nationale de vos collègues
parlementaires à l'Assemblée nationale
que le texte qu'il a
écrit pour
démontrer l'importance des des
départements ruraux est un texte qui
montre qu'à l'heure d'aujourd'hui où les
artement ruraux
existe la situation est dramatique ce
qui veut dire que la simple existence du
département n'a pas régler les problèmes
et et que il faut que nous le prenions
en compte et que nous avons sans doute
des efforts particuliers à faire
collectivement sur un certain nombre de
départements très rurau en grave
difficulté ou peut-être un petit nombre
plus petit ENF ou équivalent de
département urbains également en grand
difficulté et que notre règle de
péréquation ne suffira pas et que il
faut qu'on se pose aussi ensemble
effectivement
la l'assiette fiscale la question de
l'assiette fiscale de moi je dis
toujours le département le débat sur les
départements quel est ce débat c'est qui
finance la solidarité est-ce que ce sont
des assiettes fiscales territoriales
effectivement très large mais qu'on ne
peut pas appeler non plus de façon
déraisonnable est-ce que c'est son les
personnes par rapport à ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer de ticket modérateur
pour la pas est-ce que ce sont les
familles ce serait une double peine sur
la succession nous en sommes tous
convaincus où est-ce qu'il y a une part
de solidarité TER nationale pardon à
imaginer je le crois et vous avez raison
monsieur Savari sur le sujet PPE RSA ASS
et are qu'on avait oublié dans dans ce
schéma global d'aide aux personnes les
plus en difficulté il y a un vrai sujet
parce que les départements qui ont peu
de population ne peuvent pas être à ce
point solidaire des populations les plus
en difficulté donc ce sujet est un sujet
majeur et un sujet non pas de débat
départemental ou rural c'est un sujet de
débat national sur le financement de la
solidarité et j'entends votre argument
de l'article 40 c'est vrai que sur un
certain nombre de points nous étions
d'accord et et que peut-être en amont de
la discussion FAA qu'on revoit ces
sujets le financement de la solidarité
sur les établissements particulier et
j'ai je mets de côté parce que j'utilise
cet argument comme illustration de mon
propos mais aujourd'hui la simple
existence des départements euh ne règle
pas le problème et si moi je demande une
réforme de la DGF et si je demande à ce
qu'il y ait un député et un sénateur qui
s'occupe de l'analyse de DGF aujourd'hui
c'est parce que le milieu rural euh ne
peut pas continuer à vivre avec une DGF
qui n'est assise que sur le bâti et la
population et que si on veut ne pas
supprimer l'équivalent d'un département
tous les 10 ans si on veut garder notre
terre agricole notre indépendance
alimentaire si on veut garder la
périmède de captage les ns les Natur
2000 dont nous avons tous besoin ne
serait-ce que pour respirer et bien il
faut arrêter de n'avoir comme seule base
que le bâti ce qui veut dire que les
mètres carrés précieux industriels qu'on
connaît et qui doivent être protégés
portuaires et j'en passe doivent
s'accompagner hautement des mètres
carrés précieux agricooles et de
protection de nos espaces nous avons
besoin de cela pour vivre pour se battre
à partir de 935 440 sur l'indépendance
alimentaire qui est gravement en danger
parce que le système d'importation des
protéines végétales que je radote tout
le temps va s'arrêter bref nous avons
besoin de travailler sur une assiette
desgf qui prenne en compte la nécessité
de protéger les mètres carrés agricoles
et les mètres carrés des espaces dont
nous avons parfaitement besoin euh pour
vivre et et quand on regarde à côté la
la demande de solidarité et et et un peu
la la l'absès de fixation sur les
métropole je rappelle que c'est le Sénat
qui a souhaité débattre des métropoles
avec certes une autre majorité en
premier mais pour bien éclairer le sujet
métropolitain mais que les métropoles
ont une responsabilité et je cite
toujours Jean-Pierre Baligand l'Intitut
de la décentralisation habitant dans un
milieu très rural et en très très grave
difficultés avec des pourcentages de
votes aux extrêmes qui approchent la
majorité euh donc ça nous interroge et
bien il me dit moi ce que je demande
milieu rural à la métropole c'est de
loger les étudiants et dans de bonnes
conditions de travailler sur leur
mobilité d'accompagner ceux qui vont en
en alternance aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas d'égalité de droit des
étudiants parce qu'il y a des familles
qui ne peuvent pas payer le logement ou
le transport donc je demande à la
métropole parce que le meilleux rural ne
veut pas et avec juste raison porter une
université c'est beaucoup trop cher y
compris sur les niveaux de Bac + 3 je
veux que la métropole accueille et et
cette obligation là de solidarité donc
c'est vrai qu'il faut aussi qu'on
apprenne à échanger sur les sujets je
vois que Monsieur mard trouve que ce que
je dit est idiot mais il y a longtemps
que ça dure donc c'est pas un problème
mais je crois que nous avons des des
sujets communs entre le rural et
l'urbain qu'il faut que nous abordions
aussi y compris euh sur les bases fiscal
de de la DGF parce que le département ne
règlera pas pas tout donc j'entends vos
remarques et entre-temps on pourra
regarder avec Marisol Touren en
particulier un certain nombre de sujets
sur lequels effectivement l'article 40
vous embêterz je reviens euh au débat
général aussi vite que possible l'absès
de fixation sur l'aide Réal est un absès
de fixation sur le contrôle alors on a
les S qui pose un problème majeur les
questions de l'urbanisme Madame Royale a
décidé de revoir un certain nombre de
procédures d'abord pas pour que les dral
changent mais pour que nos citoyens
changent parce que aujourd'hui nous
sommes à 90 % il y en a qui sont bien
placés pour le savoir de projet qui ne
voi pas le jour contenu des recours des
recours des contentieux des
manifestations des recours multiples
recours avec des projets un gros projet
en terme d'urbanisme aujourd'hui dépasse
10 ans je parle de gros projets donc on
a un vrai sujet de procédure à réécrire
de contentieux en amont et non pas en
aval bref tout ça est est à l'œuvre
entre André Vallini et et Monsieur
Mandon et Madame RAL on a un vrai sujet
et c'est pas l'dral le problème c'est
nos procédures c'est nos procédures
c'est nos normes c'est nos règlements
donc là nous voulons ABS ent revoir cela
parce que le fonctionnaire qui fait son
travail fait appliquer le droit et on ne
peut pas le lui reprocher mais en
revanche quand on a fait consultation de
nos fonctionnaires pour savoir queles
seraient les simplifications ils ont
expliqué leur dur vie et le fait que ils
estiment que notre réglementation n'est
pas adaptée à la réalité d'aujourd'hui
et ils proposeent eux-mêmes des
simplification des réécritures je pense
que sur les je je crois pas que le sujet
soit celui des dral seulement mais des
direct et de RAL quel quel personnel
doivent être mis à disposition des
régions ou bien quel personnel auront
ils ont un droit de choix vous le savez
sans doute que c'est direct et RAL mais
aussi et c'est ce que nous essayons de
faire sur la revue d'émission donc qui
sera publiée en février après les
49 évaluation de politique publique qui
ont été conduites dont 35 sont terminés
et sont lisibles dire vous pouvez
demander les documents sur ces
évaluations politique publique on se
souvient de celle sur les 81 milliards
actuels d'euros dépenses fiscales
comprises d'aide aux entreprises
françaises quand on voit notre taux de
chômage on a un vrai sujet donc
effectivement on a un certain nombre
d'évaluations de politique publique à
regarder de près je passe le logement et
bien d'autres elles sont à votre
disposition après ces évaluations de
politique publique plus la revue
d'émission qui sera donc publiée en
février je pense que l'idée est retenue
d'avoir des débats sans loi mais
simplement des débats avec les
commissions ad hoc pour voir comment on
va pouvoir faire évoluer les missions de
l'État l'État va fermer un certain
nombre de missions inutiles mais en même
temps Bernard casenuve et j'ai
entendu le sujet en particulier du 1 de
l'article je je n'y reviens pas nous
feront ouverture mais Bernard casneuve
travaille sur l'administration
territoriale de la République de l'État
pardon et moi de la République avec
André et donc nous pensons aujourd'hui
que l'échelon des artemental est un
échelon qui a été délaissé après l'arat
l'arat était une bonne idée elle n'est
pas allée au bout de son objectif elle a
explosé sur le la question je le dis
franchement je ne me cache derrière
aucun aucune langue de bois elle a
explosé sur la RGPP et du coup on a
remis au niveau des régions un certain
nombre d'expertises qui sont
nécessairire sur les départements donc
nous voulons retrouver le rôle du
préfet préfet région sur les grandes
stratégies on a besoin de lui mais le
préfet pour coordonner les services de
l'État nous avons fait quelques études
sur les DDI et avec les DTM et les DDI
c'estd cette notion
d'interministérialité des services y
compris à l'air départementale le
Premier ministre et le ministre de
l'Intérieur sont convaincus avec le
président de la République que si nous
ne remettons pas de l'ingénierie sur un
certain nombre de départements nous
avons tort et enfin le dernier point qui
est à l'étude aujourd'hui c'est la
culture du contrôle nous avons besoin de
contrôle y compris parce que les
entreprises en ont besoin pour
l'exportation y compris parce que si on
n pas le cachet du contrôle à
l'abottoire on peut pas vendre ces
protéines animales à un certain nombre
de pays nous avons une forte demande
d'organisation du contrôle sur ce sujet
en particulier pour éviter qu'on importe
n'importe quoi et qu'on exporte
malheureusement des produits qui sont de
qualité mais pas reconnus comme tel donc
on
a réécriture du contrôle à mettre en
œuvre pour aider l'ensemble des des
acteurs de de économie comme des
territoires et puis à regarder les
procédures et vous serez appelé si vous
l' acceptez je après tout il n'y a pas
que la loi il y a aussi le débat qui
peut faire avancer les choses à débattre
des propositions que l'État aura reçu de
sa revue l'émission je ferme parce que
je veux aller vite il y aura-t-il un
amendement gouvernemental sur Paris
Marseille les métropoles je je vais en
désordre parce que je suis obligé de
partir sur la question des transports
maritimes que nous aurions mal géré donc
j'ai une réunion ensuite sur la question
des et des transports maritimes sur
lesquels effectivement nous sommes
appelés sur Paris et Marseille nous nous
aurons donc un débat sur le statut des
territoires un amendement pardonnez-moi
sur le statut des territoires l'idée
c'est de ne pas revenir à ce que vous
avez communément rejeté vous avez rejeté
un syndicat de
PCI Paris Métropole propose à nouveau le
syndicat de PCI que vous avez rejeté
monsieur kenb il a fait allusion tout à
l'heure je ne vois pas comment
le Sénat reviendrait sur la position
qu'il avait prise lors de la loi M
puisque le Sénat est à l'origine et
c'est quand même magnifique de la
métropole de grandpis et on le remercie
compte tenu des études de l'OCDE compte
tenu de vos positions compte tenu des
demandes de Paris Métropole il nous
semble qu'il faut donner droit à un
statut des territoires pour qu'il
puissent gérer des personnels et des
compétences de dites des anciennesepci
et transféré par la métropole les deux
sujets développement économique logement
transport et je réponds à ceux qui
s'inquiètent sur la grande couronne ces
deux sujets étant largement liés on peut
trouver une solution j'espère qu'on
trouvera une solution donc je m'engage à
ce que cet amendement soit déposé
naturellement avant vos débats même s'il
n'est pas parfait il sera en tout cas
perfectible et nous le déposerons en
revanche sur la grande couronne et
l'inquiétude
exprimé nous avons voulu et tenu à ce
qu'un certain nombre de d'outils de
grand développement je pense à roissie
je pense à sacly je pense à marneavallée
je pense à votre grand ensemble de
valdoise qui est un des plus dynamiques
que nous connaissions en ce moment avec
ces outils que vous avez nous avons tenu
à les garder à l'extérieur il y a un
grand problème de lien de liaison
pardonnez-moi de mobilité entre les
salariés potentiels de roisi par exemple
et un certain nombre de territoires nous
devons porter ce sujet nous porterons ce
sujet il y a bien sûr dans la continé du
gouvernement précédent qui avait raison
de poser le la la ligne de Grand Paris
Express donc on ne va pas remettre en
question ce qui avance on y a même mis
quelques milliards en revanche il y a
des des zones comme la vôtre dans
lesquels effectivement il y a des
impossibilités puisque pratiquement pour
travailler d'une commune X à roissi il
faut revenir par Paris pour repartir de
l'autre côté c'est abérrant donc nous
allons engager ce travail avec la grande
et l'île de France donc je rappelle
qu'elle a la compétence transport
qu'elle a un outil opposable elle est la
seule aujourd'hui à l'avoir et qu'il
faut qu'à l'intérieur de cette
enchevêtrement institutionnel on y voit
un peu plus clair donc on est d'accord
pour avancer
là-dessus donc monsieur l'évaporation
des départements alors je ne sais pas où
c'est écrit peu importe dire que on peut
se
tromper sur l'échelan mais j'ai
dit je suis le président de votre
commission on va pas discuter sur ce qui
n'est plus à l'ordre du jour en revanche
vous avez raison de poser le lien
économie formation professionnelle
service postebas conseignement supérieur
en recherche votre question est tout à
fait pertinente pour non mais
pardonnez-moi votre question est une
Excell je ne sais pas comment dire pour
que pas avoir l'air de vous juger vous
souvenez monsieur yes que dans un mandat
précédent si vous n'aviez pas été là je
n'aurais gure progressé donc euh je veux
vous dire que sur ce sujet-là euh on
a ouvert la porte de l'accompagnement
vers l'emploi qui suit ce que vous avez
dit je on a prévenu le président du
Sénat après le président de la
commission des lois que ce sujet est
ouvert monsieur Larcher est l'ancien
ministre du Travail qui a rassemblé la
NPE et les acidiques si c'est fait
sinon l'idéal e été de décentraliser les
ane et de garder les assédiques au
niveau national malheureusement ou
heureusement moi je ne veux pas juger du
passé on a maintenant Pôle emploi et je
ne sais pas couper Pôle Emploi coup pas
donc je ne coupe pas pour l'emploi et
nous allons proposer monsieur le
Président une expérimentation au sens de
l'article 72 de de la Constitution donc
convention par convention nous allons
proposer cette expérmentation je sais
que de votre côté vous vous allez sans
doute proposer des amendements nous
n'allons pas proposer la création d'un
nouveau service régional mais des
conventions d'objectifs et de moyens
entre l'outil et la région peut-être des
mises à disposition de personnel c'était
le vœu de monsieur le Président du Sénat
et de monsieur le président de la
commission des lois il n'y aura pas une
autorité mais un chef de Filat dans ce
cas puisque il nous faudra au moins un
mandat pour voir si tout cela fonctionne
je vous dis que l'opposition la plus
forte que je que j'entends est celle des
missions locales euh c'est pas l'état
qui est le plus on l'a vu tout le monde
hier madame voilà donc d'autres pistes
peuvent être explorés comme la montée en
puissance des régions aussi au conseil
d'administration de Pôle
Emploi ce n'est pas rien d'être présent
dans un conseil
d'administration le transfert de la
tutelle des missions locales et des
maisons de l'emploi aux région qui fait
débat mais de j'ai envie de vous dire
aussi violent que le départ que que
celui sur les départements et la fusion
des structures d'accompagnement à
l'emploi à l'échelle régionale nous
avons posé tout sur la table nous sommes
en phase d'expérimentation avec André
Bini Thierry Mandon le ministère de
l'Emploi et pour voir comment tout ça
peut s'articulier et nous ferons
proposition mais nous attendons
également les votes dont on sait
qu'elles seront forcément pertinentes
n'est-ce pas monsieur yes sur le postbac
vous avez
raison les
BTS sont à la fois des outils très
qualifiant parfois des outils refuges
une famille qui n'a pas les moyens
d'offrir une formation longue choisit le
BTS donc il faut aussi que nous fassions
attention à l'égalité des possibles pour
les jeunes mais ce sujet sur
l'enseignement supérieur est ouvert
aujourd'hui il n'est pas ouvert sur la
pédagogie il est ouvert sur les
contenants par sur les contenu en
revanche il est totalement ouvert sur
les transferts de technologie les
incubateurs universitaires et de les
lycées créent des centres de ressources
techniques les lycées techniques avec
leur BTS cré les CRT qui sont de
merveilleux outils de transfert donc
c'est vrai que sur ces outilslà la
tutelle de la région apparaît une
tutelle bienveillante et peut-être à
écrire je vais de plus en plus
vite
euh les uns et les autres avaient parlé
de solidarité territoriale et de
périmètres des interc je je laisse le le
détail à à André mais on a fait
qu'enverger toutes les études à la fois
l'INC cget sur les bassins de vie et les
territoires vécus pour avoir à la fois
une interco qui fonctionne au maximum et
euh qui soit efficace donc euh peut-être
et sans doute tu y reviendras un de nos
soucis reste cette appréciation négative
que j'ai entendu à l'association des
MRES de France débat sur l'interco vous
étiez nombreux sur la disparition de la
commune l'interco est le seul moyen à
mon sens pour sauver la commune il y a
beaucoup de communes qui ne peuvent plus
répondre demande de service de leur
citoyens et je pense que
l'intercommunalité forte est le seul
moyen d'y répondre il faut qu'on soit
très précis sur ses compétences j'ai
entendu que l'intérêt communautaire
était consubstantiel de la pensée de la
MF je ne suis pas certaine que dans tous
les cas il faille laisser le choix c'est
toujours le problème du heur entre le
désir et le droit même si le droit est
souple même si je crois beaucoup à la la
société du contrat il y a quand même sur
un certain nombre de compétences sans
doute à à ordonner les choses donc le le
seul de 20000 est et documenter comme
dirait certain nombre de euh nos
collègues euh mais André y
reviendra j'ai entendu euh à partir de
mais madame lard nous a quitté mais non
elle est là euh sur les grands enjeux
les grands dessins moi j'entends
toujours ça et j'attends qu'on me les
écrive je dire je l'ai souvent dit si
vous vous avez la solution pour écrire
en 30 lignes le grand dessin de cette
histoire moi je nai qu'un c'est
redresser le pays redresser le pays
c'est répondre à ce que demandent nos
citoyens aujourd'hui demande de l'emploi
bien évidemment mais il demande de
pouvoir vivre correctement où ils sont
il demande de plus en plus de services
et comment on met en adéquation cette
demande forte la nécessité de redresser
le pays c'est-à-dire on défend ou on ne
défend pas mais le cice est un
engagement financièrement lourd qui nous
oblige par rapport aux dotations des
collectivités territoriales les 50
milliards d'économies un engagement très
lourd par rapport au collectivité
territoriale je ne vois pas comment on
aurait demandé participation mais
l'enjeu global c'est le redress du pays
moi je crois que tous les territoires ne
sont pas simplement des territoires de
vie des citoyens ce sont des des
facteurs de production c'est horrible de
dire ça parce que je me dégage de la
culture qui est une culture empathique
de l'individu et du territoire mais
c'est vrai que ce sont des facteurs de
production et qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
des territoires qui créent moins de
valeur qu'il ne pourrai le créer parce
que les structures ne peuvent pas
répondre on discutait avec un président
de conseil général récemment sur je suis
à 10h de ma capitale régionale à 12h de
Paris j'ai besoin moi d'avoir une
structure aéroportuaire oui il y a
quelques projets de ce type qui doivent
être euh accompagné parce que sur un
certain nombre de territoires il y a pas
d'autres solution sauf à perdre ce
territoire comme entrant dans les
facteurs de production territoriale de
la France donc oui répondre aux
inégalités territoriales oui il y a bien
sûr les la ressource mais il y a aussi
l'ingénierie je reste persuadé
aujourd'hui que les territoires les plus
fragiles sont ceux où il y a pas
d'ingénierie et on ne peut pas répondre
aux appels à projet qui sont quand même
des écritures assez libérales de la
l'action publique aux manifestations
d'intérêt ou autres on a un vrai sujet
c'est vrai quand il y a pas d'assistant
parlementaire parto cette expression
pour écrire le projet de la petite
communauté de commune rurale ce projet
ne voit pas le jour on a un vrai souci
et on a un vraie réflexion à porter et
quand on crée la solidarité territoriale
c'est avec cette idée que certains
territoire auront besoin d'une
solidarité en terme d'ingénierie et
d'accompagnement et quand on parle des
serv servic marchand on était obligé de
l'écrire pourquoi parce que la
compétence économique est donnée aux
régions et quand on parle des services
marchands on pense au
multiservice on pense au dernier
commerce d'une commune rurale et son
agence postale on pense à ces petits
outils privés donc marchands appartenant
au secteur marchand qui ont besoin d'une
aide et on pense même à de regroupement
de de médecins ou de profession
paramédical qui appartiennent au
domaines libéral donc au secteur
marchand et qui peuvent avoir besoin
d'un soutien donc il fallait l'écrire
pour éviter qu'à un moment donné un
citoyen en appel au droit pour éviter
ces difficulté donc c'est pourquoi nous
l'avons écrit ce sont des outils que
vous connaissez par
cœur sur ce dessin toujours
personnellement je je le redis je je
pense que il faut sortir de la
concurrence entre les territoires pour
arriver à une vraie coopération moi
quand j'ai défendu les routes au niveau
de de la région c'était en disant que
les départ certains départements de ne
peuvent plus les porter et qu'au fond la
compétence régionale obligé à une
péréquation à la fois de fait et de
droit pour porter ses routes si le Sénat
pense différemment il pense différemment
mais je rappelle qu'on a une conférence
territoriale de l'action publique dans
lesquelles à ce moment-là il faudra
parler aussi des solidarités concernant
les collèges l'idée c'était gardons nous
plusieurs employeurs sur des cités
scolaires si euh les parlementaires
pensent majoritairement que le collège
est mieux géré au niveau du département
alors regardons de près regardons de
près et c'est peut-être dans la
conférence territoriale de l'action
publique que la région va demander à tel
département ou tel interco de gérer une
cité scolaire lycée collège parce que il
y a certaines régions qui demandent et
qui vont demander qui l'ont déjà exprimé
fortement à ce que les certains lycées
soient aussi géré à condition que la
ressource soit transférée par la
collectivité régionale bien entendu par
par des départements donc il faut pas
croire qu'il y a une cette espèce
d'opposition qui soit dogmatique entre
les régions et les départements je pense
que euh si on a fait cette conférence et
je rebondit sur ce qui a été dit sur la
clause de compétence générale la clause
de compétence générale on l'a réinstallé
pendant la période transitoire parce
qu'on avait pas la conférence
territoriale de l'action publique vous
l'aviez supprimé ça posait un certain
nombre de problèmes y compris pour les
multiservices euh une aide aéroportuaire
et j'en passe donc on l'a remise dans
cette période transitoire on peut
l'enlever à nouveau parce que on a cette
conférence territoriale de l'action
publique et qu'on a créé la clause de
solidarité territoriale qui évite un
recours destucteurs dont on n pas besoin
sur les départements je je crois que je
vais arrêter là parce que j'ai cette
réunion est sur les transports maritimes
et commencé je vais demander
à André de continuer y compris sur la
responsabilité concernant les Fonds
structurels et des choses de ce type ou
je dis juste sur les fonds structurels
si tu veux on revient de la réunion avec
la commissaire il y a 10 jours nous
avons écrit la responsabilité parce que
la gestion des fonds structurels esttant
confié à nos conseils régionaux
désormais euh la responsabilité en cas
de manquement doit être portée par celui
qui gère les fonds structurels donc
c'est bien pour le transfert de la
gestion des fonds structurels que nous
avons écrit que l'État ne portera pas
les pénalités si une région n'est pas à
la hauteur de ce qu'on lui demande
d'être ou si elle fait des erreurs en
revanche bien sûr sur la part FSE qui
peut être utilisé par exemple pour des
entreprises intermédiaires pour des
actions d'accompagnement vers l'emploi
d'un certain nombre de jeunes chômeurs
l'état restera responsable parce que ça
se contractualise et je pense que nous
éviterons des contentieux inutiles avec
la Commission et je demande si je veut
bien à André de continuer pour que
j'aille m'occuper des ports et des
transports maritimes madame la ministre
merci du temps que vous nous avez
consacré de la précision de vos réponses
et effectivement donc monsieur le
ministre si vous voulez bien compléter
un certain nombre de réponses sur les
points qui restent en suspens excusez-m
oui donc sur les les entreprises de de
service non marchand monsieur Savari
vient d'avoir la réponse il y avait une
question sur le La certification des
comptes des grandes collectivités
territoriales dont les produits de
fonctionnement sont supérieurs à 200
millions d'euros il s'agit donc quand on
certifie des comptes de viser à assurer
leur régularité leur sincérité et leur
fidél
il y a des réticences c'est vrai de la
part des collectivités locales et de
leurs élus à s'engager dans un
dispositif perçu comme suspicieux
d'abord et puis surtout comme lourd et
coûteux en fait le dispositif qui est
proposé est
facultatif facultatif il ne concerne que
les que les collectivités dont le les
produits je le répète de fonctionnement
sont supérieurs à 200 millions
d'euros il est protecteur pour ses
collectivités parce que la convention
précise le champ le référentiel et les
moyens avec avis des ministres
compétents il est progressif et un bilan
intermédiaire sera fait à 3 ans et
définitif à 8 ans pour les collectivités
qui se seront porté candidates et
volontaires à cette
certification je reviens de mot sur les
finances et la DGF la cveae aussi
puisque lorsqu'on parle des finances
notamment qui seront nécessaires aux
régions pour exercer leurs nouvelles
compétences on évoque immédiatement
c'est normal la CVAE tout ça sera en
débat dès l'année prochaine dès les mois
qui viennent dans le casadre de la
préparation du PLF 2000 16 et et ça
rejoindra la réflexion que nous aurons
qui est liée évidemment sur la réforme
de la DGF dont je parlais avanttiier à
la tribune de la discussion budgétaire
de du PLF 2015 il faut non seulement
réformer globalement la DGF la rendre
plus lisible plus simple et plus
équitable notamment à l'égard du milieu
rural et et il faudra faire des
transferts de
fiscalité sans doute des départements
vers les régions en terme de
CVAE étant précisé que tout ça doit être
adapté aux compétences qui resteront
exercées par les département et aux
nouvelles compétences qui seront
confiées aux
régions je pointe d'ailleurs
euh chez les présidents de région une
petite contradiction dans le fait que il
ne souhait pas forcément beaucoup de
transfert de compéten à part l'économie
mais beaucoup de transfert de CVAE
et moi je réponds chaque fois au
président de région vous ne pouvez pas
demander beaucoup de CVAE si vous dites
par avance que vous refusez toutes les
compétences qu'on voudrait
éventuellement vous transférer donc le
débat aura lieu bien sûr avec les
associations d'élus au sein du Comité
des finances locales et d'abord au Sénat
et dans votre
commission sur les les communes moi je
partage évidemment ce qu'a dit
marieelise Lebranchu la seule façon de
sauver les communes françaises c'est
l'intercommunalité elles l'ont bien
compris d'ailleurs depuis 20 ans on a
assisté à
mouvement considérable une révolution
silencieuse sur nos territoires qui
continue d'ailleurs hein j'ai des
chiffres ici au 1er janvier 2013 depuis
la loi de 2010 au 1er janvier 2013 200
mouvements avaient lieu de fusion de
rattachement de commun isolé et au 1er
janvier 2014 on était à 300 en 2 ans
nous avons connu une diminution de 2600
à
intercommunalités 1600 à 2100 en 2 ans
c'est énorme donc la révolution
silencieuse s'accélère en plus et la loi
de 2010 a eu un effet bénéfique notre
volonté est d'aller encore plus
loin pas forcément très vite mais en
tout cas un peu plus loin et même
beaucoup plus loin pour certains puisque
20000 habitants paraîtent un seuil très
élevé la plupart d'entre vous l'ont dit
ce seuil il pourrait être s'il est
retenu par le législateur il pourrait
être évidemment abaissé par des
dérogations nombreuses qu'on pourra
pourra comment dire don on pourra
multiplier les critères démographiques
géographiques
kilométrique et cetera maintenant si le
législateur souhaite abaisser ce seuil
on est prêt bien sûr à y réfléchir
certains parmi vous souhaitent même le
supprimer totalement il faut faire
attention quand il n'y a plus de seuil
les choses bougent moins
vite lorsqu'il y a un seuil avec des
dérogations ça oblige quand même à à
réfléchir à se poser des questions la
vraie question que beaucoup se posent et
moi je la ressens sur mon territoire
comme on dit et dans toute la France
parce que je circule beaucoup c'est que
les élus nous disent on a déjà dû bouger
depuis la loi de 2010 pour monter à plus
de 5000 pour ceux qui étaient en dessous
on a dû redécouper les canton ça n'est
pas le même sujet mais c'est quand même
un sujet connexe et vous nous remettez
en chantier une carte intercommunale
j'entends tout ça bien
sûr donc on va en débattre et le Sénat
donnera évidemment un avis très
circonstancier très très autorisé et
très écouté monsieur le Président mesard
sur ces questions
toujours je reviens aux communes
euh j'ai un exemple à vous citer du
conseil général de lisè où nous
débattions il y a 15 jours de la
répartition de
subvention je ne citerai pas le nom de
la commune même si le maire ne le
prendrait pas forcément mal elle a 89
habitants elle s'est lancée dans un
projet très modeste à l'échelle du
département très important pour elle de
rénovation de sa salle des fêtes
elle est subventionné pour ce projet à
90 % par l'Europe la Région le
Département la communauté de commune et
il manque 10 % oui il il manque 10 % et
elle ne les a pas et le maire de cette
commune nous demande de financer les 10
% mais oui mais ça existe encore
alors c'est vous
dire poser la question de la
justification à ce jour de commune de
cette
importance
et si vous dire si la PPL la proposition
de LO pélissar et celle de Madame
pieresbon est bienvenue sont bienvenu
dans beaucoup de départements et là
encore ça bouge énormément ces deux
texte la future loi dont que vous avez
adopté hier matin en commission des lois
je crois qui vient bientôt en décembre
euh au
Sénat cette loi suscite beaucoup
d'intérêts beaucoup beaucoup d'intérêts
dans mon département j'en suis à près
d'une dizaine de fusions qui sont
envisagés sur les compétences des des
départements et des régions d'abord sur
les départements si on reprend le texte
de ce qu'a dit manuel Vals en avril
2000 de cette année 2014 il annoncé que
le débat allait s'ouvrir d'ici 2021 sur
l'avenir des départements il ajouté
moi-même manuel Vals je suis favorable à
leur suppression mais je propose
d'engager le débat jamais annoncer la
suppression des départements avec une
date coupprès jamais il a dit que lui
était favorable et qu'il fallait qu'on y
réfléchisse d'ici 2021 en tout cas tout
ça derrière nous ce qu'il faut savoir
maintenant c'est que on va de plus en
plus vers et ça heurte beaucoup les
cartésiens que nous sommes je n'ai pas
dit les Jacobins mais on peut être
Girondins et cartésiens les cartésiens
que nous sommes sont habitués à un
jardin à la française en terme
d'administration territoriale de la
République voilà et et on sait bien que
ce modèle n'est plus n'est plus celui
qui convient aujourd'hui et en en disant
cela je réponds à à Jean-Pierre Sueur
qui demandait quel est votre dessin
votre grand
dessin
mais on peut avoir un grand dessin et
une ambition modeste le grand dessin
parce que c'est un grand dessin c'est
d'être utile au territoire d'être utile
aux collectivités territoriales à
remplir le mieux possible les missions
difficiles qui sont les leurs alors
voilà c'est une loi qui a évolué euh au
fil des mois pourquoi parce que le
gouvernement a écouté le Parlement et
les associations d'élus c'est une loi
qui donne des outils aux régions aux
départements aux
intercommunalités pour rendre les
meilleurs services publics aux citoyens
et aux usagers qui sont on le sait de
plus en plus exigeants et je crois que
ce qui caractérise notre démarche dans
la poursuite de ce grand dessin d'être
utile au collectivité territoriale c'est
le pragmatisme la France n'a plus besoin
d'être administrée de la même façon de
Lille à Perpignan ou de la Bretagne à
l'Alsace j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure la
collectivité un statut particulier que
souhaite créer les Savoyards ça pose un
problème parce que au moment où l'on
renforce les régions et la future grande
région au Vergne ronalpe notamment sur
le plan économique il serait dommage que
une partie importante de cette région
une partie importante sur le plan
économique les deux savois fassent en
quelque sorte et entre guillemets
Sécession puisque dans cette
collectivité à statut particulier les
Savoyards voudrai évidemment mettre le
développement
économique donc il y a un vrai souci on
en parle avec les les présidents des
deux départements mais il faut
évidemment il faut évidemment adapter
l'administration territoriale de la
République aux différents territoires de
la République et je renvoie pour
terminer un rapport passionnant que vous
connaissez mieux que quiconque qui est
le rapport du sénateur Alain Bertrand
sur l'hyperruralité notamment sur le
rôle des conseillers générauxx et sur la
taille des intercommunalités le sénateur
Alain Bertrand que j'ai reçu il y a
quelques jours avec qui j'ai passé 1
heure3 formidable parce qu'en plus il
est très sympathique le sénateur
Bertrand dit à quel
point le sénateur Alain Bertrand dit à
quel point il est important notamment en
milieu rural d'avoir des
intercommunalités de taille suffisante
pour avoir de l'ingénierie pour avoir un
DGS pour pouvoir rendre des services à
la
population
comment 40000
non non non mais pas en milieu rural
c'est pas possible si vous dites que
20000 c'est déjà trop alors c'est non
mais le le sénateur Bertrand sénateur de
la lozer s'il y a un département rural
c'est bien celui-ci lui considère que il
ne faut pas avoir des intercommunalités
trop petites sinon elles ne pourront pas
faire ce qu'on attend d'ell voilà
monsieur le Président de la Commission
des l ce que je voulais vous dire pour
compléter ce qu' avait dit Marie Lise
Lebranchu voilà pour cette audition
commune d'André Vallini secrétaire
d'État à la réforme territoriale et de
Marie Lise le branchu ministre de la
décentralisation vous avez pu l'entendre
ils ont dû faire face à une certaine
inquiétude ude du côté des sénateurs sur
ce projet de loi nôtre nouvelle
organisation territoriale de la
République ce texte qui prévoit les
nouvelles compétences des territoires
Région Département
intercommunalité communes alors depuis
cette audition et bien la discussion
générale sur ce texte s'est tenue au
Sénat les 16 et 17 décembre rappelons
que sur ce projet de loi et bien le
gouvernement a tenté de lâcher du l'Est
notamment sur la question de la
suppression du département qui qui n'est
plus à l'ordre du jour également sur le
seuil des intercommunalités seuil sur
lequel et bien manuel Vals le Premier
ministre s'est annoncé prêt à la
négociation reste à voir maintenant si
les promesses seront tenues et seront
suivies des faits vous pouvez toujours
voir et revoir toutes les auditions sur
notre site
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée sur
les chaînes
parlementaires